fait pas tout seul dans son coin on est
dans un truc vraiment de coopération de
partage de partage
l'hiver est la période à laquelle le
sahara renaît elle n'est pas lignée des
oasis sont l'objet de récolte
les gens attendent l'événement le plus
important de l'année
le festival du désert mais cette
compétition est très dur
les principaux chameliers ont passé
l'année à se préparer pour un marathon
éreintant la veille de la course
une forte tempête de sable se lève faire
face à la puissance de la nature est un
défi permanent
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission décrypteront
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 18 février 2e journée
l'examen de la réforme des retraites à
l'assemblée nationale après des premiers
échanges parfois houleux
les députés se sont attaqués aujourd'hui
aux milliers d'amendements d opposition
alors que dans le même temps s'ouvrait
est la conférence de financement en
présence des partenaires sociaux la
sphère griveaux l'activiste russe piotr
pawlenty qui mise en examen et placé
sous contrôle judiciaire ce soir tout
comme sa compagne alexandra de taddeo un
peu plus tôt c'est à diffusion de vidéos
à caractère sexuel qui avait conduit le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
benjamin griveaux à se retirer de la
course de la mairie de paris
[Musique]
lutter contre toutes manifestations du
séparatisme islamistes emmanuel macron
visite à mulhouse a dévoilé son plan de
bataille
un parmi les annonces le chef de l'état
a indiqué son souhait de mettre fin au
système des imams des tâches est envoyé
en france par d'autres pays et sa
volonté également de favoriser
l'organisation du culte musulman
[Musique]
une année sans je reçois le soutien d'un
groupe de son 17 médecins qui dénonce la
torture psychologique infligé au
fondateur de wikileaks
une lettre publiée dans la revue
médicale the lancet t qui met en cause
le gouvernement britannique
un tribunal discutera de l'extradition
du fondateur de wikileaks vers les états
unis la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
deuxième jour de débats sur la réforme
des retraites pour les députés au menu
les amants montra nombreux déposée par
l'opposition un plus de 40000 déposée
par la majorité par barton en majorité
par les insoumis et les communistes
une journée de travail est chargé donc
mais aussi houleux souvent on retrouve à
l'assemblée nationale
notre reporter guillemin rossi bonsoir
guévin comment se déroule cette deuxième
journée de débats si on peut appeler ça
comme ça et bien écouter les débats ont
en effet commencé puisque les députés
ont commencé à examiner enfin les
premiers des très nombreux amendements à
vous l'avez dit de cette réforme des
retraites la séance d'ailleurs vient de
se terminer à il ya quelques minutes une
nouvelle séance est d'ailleurs prévue à
21h30 alors au delà du travail de fourmi
qui attend les députés puisque vous
l'avez dit plus de quarante mille
amendements 42000 et même si on prend en
compte les amendements également déposé
pour le projet de loi organique donc au
delà de ce travail plusieurs annonces
ont été faites par le président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
tout d'abord les délais dont va
bénéficier l'assemblée pour examiner
cette réforme des retraites une
troisième semaine de débats a été
ajoutée avec une pause dans les travaux
parlementaires prévues le 6 mars pour
les élections municipales et de
municipal pardon et puis richard ferrand
a également pris une disposition sur le
temps de parole considérant que la
france a soumises et le parti communiste
faisait preuve d' obstruction
parlementaire du fait des nombreux
amendements similaires déposées
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
limité la prise de parole à à un seul
orateur pour chacun de ces deux groupes
une décision qui bien entendu a
fortement de plus des plus pardon à
l'opposition qui s'est exprimé
d'ailleurs sur la tenue des débats je
vous propose de l'écouter
une chose qui m'a beaucoup surprise
c'est que j'ai trouvé que la majorité
était très peu mobilisé
notamment celle ci vu sur la motion de
rejet de la droite parce que la droite
aurait mobilisé ses troupes
la motion de rejet serait passé voilà
elle n'a été battu que de 50 voix alors
que la droite était à peu près à un
quart à un tiers de son groupe
donc ça veut dire que quand même je
trouve qu'en face la majorité pas très
et pas très mobilisés c'est un peu ce
qu'on a vu dans la commission où la
plupart des marcheurs ne disait rien et
je pense que c'est ça qui va continuer
un peu dans sa sélection ils sont pas
bien sûr cette fois ils n'ont pas les
réponses
leurs réponses sont contradictoires ils
ont bien du mal à défendre et c'est pour
ça que j'espère qu'au si on va on va le
montrer pendant les débats
parlementaires dans l'hémicycle le
ministre des retraites nous a dit je ne
veux pas du référendum parce que je veux
que la démocratie parlementaire sera
respectée et qu'on puisse aller jusqu'au
bout du débat est donc je lui ai répondu
je vais écouter monsieur le ministre
moi je suis prêt à ne pas voter la
motion référendaire
à une condition c'est que vous preniez
l'engagement qu'il n'y ait jamais de 49
3 que croyez-vous qu'il m'a répondu rien
et donc j'ai voté à maison référendaire
alors vous venez d'entendre le parti
socialiste par la voix d'olivier fort si
le parti socialiste a bien signé la
motion référendaire
hier il n'a pas signé la motion de
censure promise pourtant par jean luc
mélenchon co 2 quant aux 49 3 qui vient
d'être évoquée vous avez pu halal à
nouveau entendre olivier faure le
ministre le nouveau ministre de la santé
olivier vers ans a laissé entendre
aujourd'hui que le recours à cet article
n'était pas exclue même s'ils n'étaient
pas encore à l'ordre du jour merci
humains rossi en direct de l'assemblée
nationale et dans le même temps la
conférence de financement a donc débuté
aujourd'hui objectif ramener à
l'équilibré le système de retraite d'ici
à 2027
les organisations syndicales et
patronales ont jusqu'à fin avril pour
trouver une solution alternative à
l'instauration d'un h niveau de 64 ans
ce matin devant le ministère des
solidarités et de la santé cyril
chabanier président de la cftc s'est
montré optimiste
ça sera difficile puisqu'on n'est pas
tous d'accord sur le principe même même
delà de la réforme comme venait de le
répéter mais je pense qu'on a un
véritable enjeu on doit on doit réussir
à se mettre d'accord à trouver un
compromis je pense que c'est peut-être
un peu la dernière chance pour montrer
que le dialogue social dans ce pays peut
aboutir un consensus à un compromis
si on n'y arrive pas je pense qu'on a le
risque de donner du grain à moudre à
ceux qui pensent que cela violence peut
arriver à obtenir des résultats
donc je pense qu'on a vraiment un très
très gros enjeu en tout cas pour la cftc
on ne fera tout pour qu'on puisse
aboutir à cette conférence mais à
condition encore une fois que que
l'effort soit équilibré et pour en
parler nous sommes avec pierre roger
secrétaire national cf cgc bonsoir s'est
arrogé merci d'être avec nous premiers
jours de conférences du financement elle
était très attendue vous y avaient
participé
racontez-nous vous partager le même
point de vue que votre collègue enjeu
est de taille ça va être difficile à
goûter bon j'entends j'entends ce qu'a
dit mon collègue juste avant le début de
la conférence est lorsqu'on participe à
une négociation en principe c'est pour
essayer d'aller au bout
ceci étant dit il faut quand même
rappeler le contexte de cette
négociation
elle a été lancée pour d'une part
exprimé un que la seule solution viable
pour le gouvernement c'est la sienne en
fixant cette conférence le cadre a été
fixé très court comme délai vous ne
touchez pas au niveau des pensions que
ça ne pose pas de problème vous touchez
pas au niveau des cotisations donc il
reste un seul paramètre la durée si vous
trouver une autre solution que la shd
équilibre tel que je le propose je suis
preneur alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
vous comprenez que c'est le choix est
relativement étroit
surtout qu'aujourd'hui l'objectif
c'était de voir quelle était l'ampleur
de la situation
l'ampleur de la situation
elle est très simple j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire sur votre plateau ici même il
ya pas un problème de finances il ya pas
de problème de retraite à 2027 il ya
simplement un problème de recettes ou
l'état a décidé de ne plus apporter sa
contribution comme aujourd'hui donc de
ce fait sacrer un déficit est ce que
pour autant ces graves
alors je rappelle quand même que on
parle de 12 milliards à l'horizon 2027
par an en face leurs traites c300 325
milliards chaque année et on à 140
milliards de réserve par ailleurs leur
forme en 2024 fin 2024 la cadette la
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale aura totalement remboursé la
dette
et ça libère par an environ 17 milliards
pris comme ça est ce qu'on est obligé
nécessairement le pronom mesure
uniquement sur l'âge nous on pense qu'on
peut trouver une autre solution ce qui
est frappant dans cette conférence c'est
que tout le monde ya participé
oui sauf l'été employeur c'est à dire
qu'il n'y avait pas de représentant de
l'état cet après midi alors qu en tant
qu'employeur au financement
parlons du financement vous aviez des
membres de l'êta qui étaient des
fonctionnaires la cour des comptes et
autres qui étaient là en tant qu'expert
à deux représentants les pages
représentant de l'état en tant
qu'employeur pourrait mettre son son son
avis alors que vous aviez finalement
film autour de la table tous les
représentants syndicaux que ce soit du
côté patronal ou salariés du secteur
privé donc dit pierre roger ça veut dire
que concrètement qu on comprenne bien
parce que l'on a prévu la chance d'y
être à cette conférence qui représentait
l'état cet après midi là on laisse
on nous laisse certainement qu'il faut
interpréter ça comme une marque de
confiance
le soin de traiter le problème du
gouvernement qui nous dit bah écoute et
voilà moi j'arrête de financer parce que
j'ai moins de fonctionnaires donc je
paye moi j'ai fait des exonérations de
cotisations donc je compense pas
contrairement à ce que les loups avaient
prévu je vous donne d'après mes calculs
alors là aussi l'estimation des 2
milliards on l'a quand même regarder un
petit peu dans le détail elle est très
optimiste quand même mais elle est trop
optimiste pourquoi parce qu'en fait on a
une croissance à 1,3 qui en moyenne
prévu sur la période
c'est pas évident quand on voit le passé
un chômage à 7%
or on c'est vrai qu'il ya une tendance
un peu à l'amélioration mais surtout un
gain de productivité de productivité
parlons à 1,50 on n'y est pas du tout un
5 1 % c'est grand maximum pourquoi parce
que la france crée des emplois
aujourd'hui mais ce sont des emplois de
qualité très moyenne
je veux dire on crée des
et les livreurs délire ou alors j'ai
absolument rien contre eux les garçons
qui font ou les filles qui font ce genre
de travail mais c'est pas des ingénieurs
en termes de croissance de productivité
ça n'a pas la même portée sa baisse le
chômage c'est une bonne chose ça
n'apporte pas des revenus suffisants au
long terme donc la prévision du
gouvernement et on va dire qualifié de
et là dessus tout le monde appelait à la
corde très optimistes relativement
optimiste ceci étant ça remet pas les
choses au fond avec tout ce que je vous
ai dit on a les moyens de financer
simplement la volonté politique elle est
clair c'est de dire que je veux faire
une réduction des déficits de l'état
en tant qu'employeur la solution que je
propose c'est de reporter l'âge selon
des modalités d'achat équilibre à
discuter en cours de discussion au
niveau de l'assemblée nationale et il
n'y a pas d'autre solution pour moi qui
est envisageable
en tout cas si vous la proposer j'aurai
la liberté c'est prévu dans le texte de
la refusez donc à la lumière de ce que
vous nous dites on se demande comment
les choses pourront avancer puisque on
se souvient du postulat de départ c'est
à vous de trouver des solutions si vous
les trouvez pas il y aura bien cet âge
pivot qui sera imposée par le
gouvernement on est bien d'accord c'est
un peu le barça est donc
à l'image de la conférence d'aujourd'hui
qui a ce matin a duré trois heures on a
deux séries donc ce financement on doit
le trouver en trois séances
tous trois heures sachant que la séance
de ce matin on nous a communiqué des
éléments au vendredi qu'on connaît tous
par coeur nous a déjà expliqué pendant
une heure et demie les slides qu'on
connaît tous par coeur ce qui fait que
pour commencer la discussion
organisation grosso modo vous avez 10 à
15 minutes
si on fait trois séances pour trouver
quelques milliards à raison de un quart
d'heure par organisation en trois
séances
voyez bien que il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord en 45 minutes chacun ça va être
ça va être compliqué ça veut dire qu'un
roger concrètement aujourd'hui à l'heure
où vous nous parlez ll très cette
première journée que vous êtes
pessimiste que vous avez l'impression
qu'en gros il n'y a pas vraiment de
négociation dans le réel
le message que je veux faire passer
c'est que on a à côté 1
une assemblée nationale qui fait son
rôle en tant que l'assemblée nationale
de discuter des amendements qui peuvent
entraîner des modifications du texte de
loi avec des conséquences financières
vous y croyez ça tant qu' on peut très
bien aggraver la situation
posterai l'améliorer mais bon ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que l'assemblée
chez son travail
deux des plus fins au niveau législatif
qui est normal nous à côté on parle
financement et que ça se fait de manière
parallèle sans coordination par
définition puisque nous ne sommes pas
les deux représentants de la nation au
niveau des six latif et que eux mêmes
vont pas les éléments pour discuter du
financement
avouez quand même que c'est une démarche
un peu curieuse
donc eux
comme je vous le dis une négociation est
ouverte une discussion ouverte nous y
allons avec toute la bonne foi ça
n'empêche pas d'être lucide on sait pas
le donner les moyens
clairement d'aboutir en tout cas c'est
pas comme ça qu'on a on ne sait pas la
première impression que cela donne bien
roger vous avez décidé dans votre
syndicat la cge de ces feux pardon cgc
de ne plus vous mobiliser mais tout de
même de rester dans l'intersyndicale si
ça ne devait pas aboutir
quel serait votre choix vos actions
alors le choix toute façon il appartient
au moment où on devra discuter en
fonction de l'évolution des choses ce
que je constate aujourd'hui c'est quand
même pendant l'alignement des planètes
un petit peu bizarre vous avez
effectivement une intersyndicale vous
avez à côté des professions libérales
des avocats encore ce matin dans cette
conférence la représentants sont
clairement exprimé en disant mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait là on n'a rien demandé
vous avez le medef qui représente les
grandes entreprises qui dit nous on
n'est pas le vendeur de cette réforme
et quand on dit que sur le financement
on veut maintenir
le plafond des cotisations entre 3 et 8
plafonds
vous avez un alignement des planètes qui
fait que la cgt d'accord la cfe cgc qui
représente les cadres est d'accord au
départ pourtant ce ne sont pas deux
organisations a priori qui ont
l'habitude doit avoir le même point et
le medef est d'accord moi je pose la
question lorsque vous avez la cgt la cfe
et le medef qui ont les mêmes analyses
et qui arrive aux mêmes conclusions
c'est peut-être au niveau du programme
ya peut-être un loup parle en tout cas
ça mérite qu'on se pose la question
visiblement c'est un gouvernement qui
n'a absolument pas envie de changer de
posture qui n'a qu'une hâte c'était
faire passer ce texte au plus vite et de
passer à autre chose en tout cas c'est
l'impression que ça donne
le fait que agnès buzyn a été remplacé
par olivier verrons quelle est votre
réaction ça peut ouvrir peut-être une
piste ou au contraire
ou alors ça ne change rien pour moi je
ne pense pas que ça change parce que
toute façon ce texte jette au niveau du
premier ministre s'est dit qu'il
assimile l'a conçu et l'assument c'est
clair et net
on l'a vu au fur et à mesure des
remplacements des ministres je pense que
je peux pas parler pour m'amuser mais je
pense qu'elle n'a pas vraiment eu le
choix
de ce qu'on lui a demandé ça fait partie
des la grandeur de la fonction voilà
mais pour c'est au niveau du premier
ministre les choses se passent et en
dessous ce n'est on le voit tous les
jours que la mise en forme
merci beaucoup en tout cas pierre roger
est revenu nous raconter cette première
journée de la conférence de financer un
projet des retraites merci à vous les
suites de la sphère griveaux piotr
peuvent lenski et sa compagne alexandra
de thadée ont tous deux été mis en
examen et placé sous contrôle judiciaire
l'activiste russe presque par ailleurs
toujours les détention provisoire pour
des faits de violences remontant au 31
décembre 2019 l'avocat juan branco de
son côté qui le représentait renonce à
le défendre
je lui ai suggéré quand la situation
actuelle il valait mieux qu'il prenne un
nouveau conseil à qui j'ai demandé s'il
acceptait de prendre le dossier
maître yassine bouzrou 1,3 yassine
bouzrou va épauler piotr pas blonski
mettre en visibilité des problèmes
procéduraux gravissimes qui ont sali on
a été confronté dans cette procédure
depuis le début et pour en parler nous
sommes avec stéphane rozès président de
cap conseils analyses perspectives
enseignant à sciences po et hec
également bonsoir stéphane rozès merci
d'être avec nous quand on voit
l'agitation que cela provoque depuis
plusieurs jours à ce que pour vous la
faire rivaux est devenue clairement une
affaire d'état une affaire d'état
peut-être pas dans la mesure où au fond
rapidement elle a trouvé une solution du
point de vue de
à majorité par le départ même de machin
cri vous mais c'est une affaire qui a
secoué l'état très certainement vous
l'avez dit ça a été une sorte d' onde de
choc parce que le candidat la république
en marche au moment des faits était
aussi ministre du gouvernement et donc
il ya un effet de stupeur s'il n'ya
jamais eu comme ça en cours de campagne
municipale
le une tête de lice comme ça en
métropole aussi importante qui se retire
un et donc agnès buzyn à la charge peu
évidente de reprendre le flambeau sur
pareil et donc l'arrivée d'agnès biesen
est une personnalité forte importante
dans le dispositif la marque roignot
font tourner la page
politiquement de ça alors il peut y
avoir des effets encore de cette affaire
sur la philosophie de l'exécutif sur les
choses par exemple les réseaux sociaux
va y avoir des développements
judiciaires visiblement on l'a vu dans
les effets donc il va y avoir encore des
ddd traînée de cette affaire au plan
donc peut-être éventuellement législatif
au plan judiciaire c'est clair mais la
séquence politique elle même a été
rapidement conclues par l'arrivée
d'agnès busin qui fait bouger les lignes
à paris et qui au fond remet l'attention
du public sur des dimensions politiques
et moins de morale politique
l'observateur que vous êtes direct
emmanuel macron l'exécutent le chef de
l'exécutif a plutôt bien géré cette
séquence du mieux qu'il a pu en tout cas
alors j'allais dire non
listes d'indépendants que je suis
presque une fois n'est pas coutume le
choix d'agnès busan me semble être un
très bon choix pourquoi parce que le
sujet des parisiens est au fond est ce
qu'on maîtrise toujours nous parisien le
développement de paris et le quotidien
des parisiens étaient très bousculés
dans la dernière période et shield shawn
ne réforme des retraites mais surtout le
quotidien s'est dégradée le fait que 60
% des parisiens ne souhaite pas la
reconduction d'anne hidalgo dit
suffisamment le bilan négatif qui est le
sien ce qui n'est pas coutumier des
grands mères pensent
or agnès buzyn par sa façon d'être sa
façon de faire le fait que ça soit un
médecin qu'elle soit en rupture avec le
style benjamin griveaux était un style
de disruption qui était un style
agressif qui était un style de critiques
de ses adversaires au contraire agnès
buzyn par sa façon d'être et de faire
semblant en mesure de réparer de
rassembler de pacifier et le challenge
même qu'est le sien en am en à moi
trouver une solution fait que
spontanément les parisiens se disent il
faudrait peut-être l'aider temps ça
semble incroyable le défi qui est le
sien à vous entendre à ce que ce qui
pouvait paraître comme un séisme en tout
cas une très mauvaise nouvelle pour quoi
emmanuel macron pourrait s'avérer être
une bonne nouvelle pour lui
oui absolument parce que toute façon la
campagne de benjamin griveaux était
mauvaise cédric villani qui n'avait pas
de soutien et était à son niveau
quasiment donc benjamin griveaux c'était
fini il y avait un duel annoncé anne
hidalgo rachida dati qui évidemment
auraient profité à m
dingue au deuxième tour qu'à rachida
dati n'est pas en situation de
rassembler une majorité par dire et donc
paradoxalement si manipulation
consciente
il y a eu sur la sphère griveaux la
réponse du président macron en fait peut
permettre alors le mois qui arrive va le
démontrer pas mais selon moi est la
nsbih zain a du fun du sujet des
parisiens a de bonnes chances a fortiori
si elle a dorénavant avec l cédric
villani de l'emporter la mise en examen
de la compagne de piotr pawlenty et de
ce dernier à 1 ce soir c'est la suite
logique de cette affaire rien à signaler
à ce niveau là il y à il ya des lois en
la matière est évidemment comprend
pourquoi l'exécutif a voulu n'ont pas
autant focalisé sur la faute
faites par benjamin griveaux qui a de
lui-même rendu possiblement public
quelque chose lié à sa vie privée
d'autant plus a fortiori vu les
circonstances de la relation avec la
personne et donc on comprend bien
pourquoi en réaction de défense
d'exécutif a voulu pointer au fond ce
qui ont instrumentalisé et question des
réseaux sociaux donc logiquement et
pillay a aussi eu il ya une législation
sur l'utilisation des données ou ballan
la justice entre part je suis pas
d'ailleurs du tout à se passer de ces
questions là donc la justice va faire
son travail inculpé ça veut pas dire pas
mais c'est assez logique au fond on s'y
attendait un tout petit peu que
effectivement la justice soit saisie
vous parlez de la réaction de l'exécutif
pour le secrétaire d'état d'ailleurs au
numérique cedrico il faut rétablir
justement la peur du gendarme sur
internet en permettant notamment la
justice et la police d'intervenir plus
rapidement en cas de violation de la loi
en ligne c'est une occasion toute
trouvée de formuler des restrictions
encore une fois on connaît cette
appétence sein de ce gouvernement à
vouloir maîtriser l'usagé d'internet
tels que la ferc rivaux est arrivé on a
vu député importante de la république en
marche d'hier bien il faudrait peut-être
gendarmes et aussi twitter regarder ce
qui se passe dans les autres pieds tout
ça alors bon il ya des lois il ya il ya
des instances indépendantes qui vérifie
toutes ces questions et au fond il ya
une forme de cohérence
si au fond la sphère griveaux c'est
essentiellement un problème lié à
l'articulation entre libertés publiques
liberté d'expression droit à l'intimité
du coup on voit que les choses alors je
ne sais pas le ses tricots a fait
effectivement une déclaration ce soir
vous avez raison ben on va voir ce qu'il
en est parce que entre les déclarations
et concrètement ce que l'on fait c'est
très différent parce qu'il ya aussi un
état de droit dans notre pays alors il
ya une déliquescence de l'esprit public
clairement et
aulas de la faute de benjamin griveaux
et des instrumentalisations possible
qu'elle soit par l'ultra gauche ou une
puissance étrangère par exemple la
russie mais c'est pas ça selon moi la
question essentielle
d'abord la question première d'abord a
été la faute de pinchat mengue rivaux et
donc le depor sur la question des
réseaux sociaux est un des ports dont je
me demande si au fond il va aboutir
puisque comme je les dis la situation
sur paris et éclaircies et s'ils avaient
eu manipulation ce serait l'arroseur
arrosé
et au fond les français passent à une
autre séquence parce que cette affaire
les a déstabilisés nous ne sommes pas
les états unis il ya eu des manquements
néanmoins de la part d'une personnalité
politique et les français n'aiment pas
voir des moeurs qui semble être des à
tort ou à raison des moeurs d'autres
pays s'immiscer dans le républicanisme
qui est le nôtre et on parlait des
français selon un sondage et nab pour
nos confrères de bfm tv 50 % d'entre eux
se disent choqués par la diffusion au
public de ses vidéos intimes attribué à
benjamin griveaux pourtant c'est vrai
que politique on l'a vu et journalistes
d'ailleurs semblé tenir un discours
assez unique sur les plateaux de télé
victimisant souvent je crois qu'on peut
le dire benjamin griveaux à part
peut-être quelques opinions divergentes
votre regard justement vous sur ce
traitement médiatique de cette affaire
il était assez inédit honnêtement la
question n'est pas simple moi tout de
suite j'ai dit d'abord benjamin griveaux
avait créé les conditions 8 même par le
fait qu'il avait produite cette vidéo et
qu'il avait transmises à une tierce
personne en dehors des liens familiaux
et conjugaux qui faisait que forcément
il se mettait en péril et que donc
séduit qui s'est mis en péril qui a mis
en péril de la république en marque qui
a mis en péril le débat public
ensuite il ya la question de
l'instrumentalisation politique mais au
départ il ya une origine et il n'y a des
effets et donc ça a été ma première
réaction pourquoi parce que l'homme
politique à une charge il a une
obligation c'est pas un citoyen comme
les autres et donc il doit se conformer
amis même si nous ne sommes pas les noms
et les états unis il doit protéger la
fonction hors d'un chai minc rivaux n'a
pas protégé la fonction politique il hh
était la sienne
merci beaucoup stéphane rozès un rappel
que sept présidents de conseils analyses
perspectives enseignant en sciences po
et hec mercier vous y restez avec nous
dans quelques instants
deux petites minutes nous reviendrons
sur les mesures de lutte contre le
séparatisme islamiste présenté par
emmanuel macron amellou ce soir
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
deux films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis au les chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
il ya les manches et aller yéniches il
ya les sintis et à les gitans donc on
peut voir on peut voir déjà que un souci
au niveau des roms qui sont mille et
mille pièces dehors atteindre les
considérer comme des étrangers quand on
est là en france quoi c'est qu'on est
des étrangers de france en salle aux
trois quarts de taji rien et dîners
politique ne nous appelons tous canaris
canaris signifie les gens qui
travaillent dur c'est entrer dans la
remise ils ont abattu mon frère de sang
froid n'ont appris plus tard de sa rima
et l'entorse
coeur foie gras
et d'autres non
tous les gitans du monde je pense qu'on
est les plus détestés de toutes les
autres communautés pour des mois et je
pense qu'on devrait pourtant pas de
prison 20h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindrons direct sur rt france
emmanuel mettront s'engage donc contre
ce qu'ils appellent le séparatisme
islamistes le chef de l'état est à
mulhouse où il a présenté les mesures de
son plan de lutte contre le séparatisme
islamistes au sein de la république
parmi les annonces à retenir cesser
progressivement d'accueillir des imams
détachées envoyés par d'autres pays
favoriser l'organisation du culte
musulman ou encore accompagner davantage
les associations et collectivités
territoriales on écoute notre ennemi et
à ce titre le séparatisme c'est à dire
ce phénomène que nous observons depuis
des décennies qui est une volonté de
quitter la république de ne plus en
respecter les règles d'un mouvement de
repli qui en raison d'une croyance et
d'appartenance vise à sortir du champ
républicain est ce que nous avons à
faire n'est pas comme j'ai parfois
entendu chez certains un plan contre
l'islam
ce serait une faute profonde cette
stratégie de lutte contre le séparatisme
islamistes
elle doit se construire un musée autour
de quatre lignes de force
la première c'est de reprendre le
contrôle et de lutter contre les
influences étrangères en particulier à
l'école et dans les lieux de culte c'est
ce sur quoi je veux surtout aujourd'hui
m'exprimer la deuxième c'est de
favoriser une meilleure organisation de
culte musulman en france justement dans
le respect de la laïcité et pour
s'assurer du respect de toutes les lois
de la reine troisième ligne de force
c'est de lutter avec détermination
contre toutes les manifestations du
séparatisme islamistes et du repli
communautariste qu'il génère et qui
contreviennent aux lois et règlements
c'est à dire rentrer dans le détail
parce que je viens d'évoquer
et point par point là où la loi est
ambigu là où des pratiques se sont
développées pouvoir y répondre
avec beaucoup de calme et la quatrième
ligne de force c'est de pouvoir partout
ramener la république
là où elle a un peu démissionner où elle
n'a pas toujours été au rendez-vous ou
des difficultés sont apparues que nous
n'avons pas su résoudre comme il se
devait
et pour jean luc mélenchon président du
groupe elle est fier à l'assemblée
nationale toutes les questions soulevées
par le président macron ressortent déjà
de la loi française en longueur au
milieu il faut regarder sur la loi ne
permet pas de traiter du problème des
questions vous été saluée par rosa
d'ores et déjà de la tête en cause en
matière de religion
à la différence de nombre d'autres
polémiques on peut l'avoir livre celle
de la religion plus chaque fois et la
foi et culture des trains - qui vous et
qui ne résident pas dans le dialogue et
la radio car ce qui est en jeu c'est la
paix civile et pour en parler nous
sommes avec nadia rayman à présidente de
la brigade des mers bonsoir madame
comment vous avez jugé ce discours d'
emmanuel macron s'attendait pas
franchement des annonces il a déjà
commencé en faire sur ce plan ça me
semble s'annoncer pas mal il prend la
bonne voie pour vous ou non alors moi
bon effectivement là vous connaissez mon
combat et tout ça ça fait plusieurs
années qu'on attend que justement juste
devant notre président se manifestent
justement alors moi j'ai ramené de
courrier alors on a écrit un courrier on
peut le 15 juin 2018 on alerte monsieur
notre manuel macron un autre courrier le
de ces juillet 2010 est effectivement il
fait part de la situation dans les
quartiers tout ça où on a une réponse en
me disant bravo pour le travail que vous
faites mais on n'a aucun retour
alors aujourd'hui monsieur vaincrons je
pense qu'il voyait s'il est dans son
rôle il est dans la communication qui
s'est fait ici y faire et ses
communiqués alors j'ai entendu
effectivement moment donné par les de
réconquérir les quartiers
réconquérir ça veut dire je trouve le
mot un peu mignon réconquérir c'est
reprendre les quartiers de toute façon
ça veut dire qu'on les a perdus les
quartiers il parle d'échec clairement
d'un des chefs de de communautarisme je
pense que lui il a commencé justement
son mandat avec ça il faut pas oublier
qu'il a mis dans la tête de liste pour
les villes de quartier nous a mis un
humoriste quelqu'un qui n'avait rien à
voir avec les quartiers qu'ils n'avaient
aucune expérience de terrain
c'est son copain jeter mais là tu gères
les quartiers la preuve la personne a
démissionné et moi j'avais rencontré
monsieur président avant qu'ils soient
présents sept ou huit mois je lui avais
fait effectivement une analyse de
terrain notre inquiétude est tous à ce
qui se passe dans le quartier
j'avais l'impression d'avoir en face de
moi quelqu'un je parlais d'un autre pays
et pas de la france est aujourd'hui
justement va revenir sur les mesures que
j'ai regardé avec mon équipe on a étudié
tout ça j'espère que ce n'est pas que de
la com parce que je pense qu'il faut
prendre un moment donné faut être
sérieux dans notre pays et ce qui me
fait peur c'est que quand il va
travailler encore les mains avec les
mêmes associations pour certaines
indiscrétions qu'il ya des associations
qui font un travail formidable dans les
quartiers aussi il va toujours travaillé
avec les mêmes en fin de compte on est
on s'échange
les associations on va genre fermer une
ou deux associations
mais on va laisser des associations qui
justement qu'on dénonce depuis plusieurs
années je pense qu'il va pas prendre
vraiment les grandes décisions et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les français c'est
ce qu'ils ont besoin
on n'en peut plus de vivre dans ces
quartiers où effectivement et à cette
politique je le répète tout le temps
mais pas assez la politique des grands
frères je pense qu'il faut pas oublier
un truc important macron vient de chez
monsieur hollande
il connaissait les quartiers c'est pas
quelque chose qui découvre alors on a
l'impression qu'ils découvrent les
quartiers qui découvre aujourd'hui faut
tirer le signal d'alarmé
l'appellation séparatisme islamistes on
a beaucoup parlé de ces mots qui ont
leur importance de l'art l'elysée
beaucoup tergiversé sur voilà est-ce
qu'on parle de communautarisme de
radicalisation ou l'art de séparatisme
islamistes ça vous semble être bien
choisi ce terme on nomme les choses on
une un peu pourquoi pas mais dans un
sens il nous parle de séparatistes
islamistes et dans un sens il nous a
pompé ya pas longtemps encore l'islam de
france et y travaillent pour l'islam de
france
alors effectivement nantes c'est
contradictoire pour moi c'est
contradictoire
on ne peut pas parler d'islam de france
c'est comme si qu'on parlait de
christianisme de france etc
alors aujourd'hui parle de ses parts à
10 mais on sait qu'à côté à d'autres
projets justement sur l'islam de france
on continue à former les imams on retire
les postes d'éducateurs de médiateur
leva la police etc
alors je pense et j'espère me tromper je
pense que c'est encore de la
communication est allé municipal qui
arrive est allé présidentielle mine de
rien dans trois ans je pense je pense
que les mots comprends monsieur
président effectivement peuvent paraître
pour certains effectivement on va se
dire enfin
mais pour nous qui sommes dans les
quartiers on va dire de toute façon il
faudra vraiment que cette fois ci tient
ses promesses parce que je pense qu'on
va l'attendre au tournant
particulièrement nous les quais des les
gens qui travaillent ensemble dans les
quartiers on peut plus laisser tomber
alors on va aller dans le détail de ces
mesures l'une d'entre elles notamment
emmanuel macron qui a annoncé qu'il
souhaitait arrêter le système d
détaché pour former des imams
directement sur le sol français et côté
aujourd'hui on a je le disais 300 imams
détachées qui sont envoyées en france
chaque année
et donc ce qu'ils sont et 20 en 2020
seront la dernière génération avec ce
volume et nous allons progressivement
sortir c'est à dire ne plus en faire
venir de nouveaux et laisser la période
de présence des dernier imam détachées
se poursuivre jusqu'à son terme avec là
aussi un dialogue et une amélioration
des conditions
en parallèle de sa ce que nous devons
faire et ce que nous allons faire c'est
g revenir dans un instant former des
imams en france pour qu'ils puissent
maîtriser la langue et les lois de la
république
donc nous allons ainsi progressivement
mettre fin au système des imams
détachées et là aussi de manière
progressive
opsahl moddeurs qui sont accueillis
spécifiquement chaque année à l'occasion
du ramadan
il y en a environ 300 cette sortie de ce
qu'on appelle l'islam consulaire est
elle aussi extrêmement importante pour
pouvoir réduire ses influences
étrangères
et là aussi permettre de s'assurer que
chacune et chacun respecte pleinement
les droits de la république dans un
cadre qui est connu de tous
l'un des rêves manage envoyé sourire ces
annonces elles vont quand même dans le
bon sens pour veut réduire sa science
que les i même les plus rigoureux qu'on
a ce sont des jeunes qui sont nés en
france et c'est des français justement
si on prend par exemple l'exemple de
tariq oubrou et plein d'autres justement
se sont saisis même là justement qui
sont sur le terrain depuis des années
qu'ils sont déjà formés justement en
france qui vont être nommés j'aimerais
bien qu'ils nous donnent les noms de ces
imams qui ne qui vont parvenir de
l'étranger mais qui sont sur les 1 sur
le territoire français et qui sont de
nationalité française
je prends toujours le par exemple on a
le
l'imam de drancy et haricots broue
compagnie je pense qu'il a fait
justement son son tri et ça sera
toujours la même histoire
le problème c'est pas former les imams
et encore une fois c'est pas les formes
et on n'a pas besoin de former les imams
ce que dans l'islam sont la plaque large
et ça nous regarde pas les imams les
fidèles c'est à eux de choisir leur imam
c'est pas à la république de se mêler
c'est là le séparatisme l'état doit
rester neutre doit avoir un option bien
sûr on doit observer mais c'est pas à la
france de former des imams encore moins
à la à notre république
le pierre jetée dans le jardin de la
turquie de l'algérie ça vous semble et
avec qui m'entoure je comprend
effectivement là on dans un sens il nous
parle de la colonisation il nous fait
des joueurs comme quoi qu'on était que
les français c'était les méchants et
aujourd'hui dit bon il faut faire
attention la lire et la turquie à trous
mais moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on parle
de la responsabilité de la france
les jeunes qui sont partis en syrie sont
des jeunes français ils sont pas venus
d'algérie ou de turquie ce sont des
français qui sont partis et si on
revient sur l'histoire des imams je vous
dis on n'a pas à former les imams en
forme des éducateurs des médiateurs des
policiers des enseignants les voulons
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de problème
justement avec les imams et cftc
quand même une partie la radicalisation
mejia des problèmes parce que pourquoi
parce que l'état s'en est mêlé parce que
les musulmans toujours vécu en france
depuis qu'ils sont devenus politisé
comme tariq oubrou et je pourrais en
citer d'autres
c'est depuis que la politique sont les
mêlées depuis qu'on a fait les fameux
ifta républicain et j'en passe et
l'islam de france qu'elle les problèmes
on leur a ouvert la porte en la rouvert
leurs portes à la porte de l'elysée
la porte des préfectures moi j'ai vu des
imams dans la préfecture de seine saint
denis on avait l'impression que c'était
eux c'étaient des enseignants on l'avait
appris que c'est des éducateurs on a
quand même fait appel aux imams quand il
ya eu des émeutes de banlieue en fin de
compte on leur a donné un rôle plus
important qu'il le devait animal il doit
faire appel à la prière c'est comme un
prêtre ou un rabbin et tout ça c'est
pour ça que l'on vous dit en gros ils
ont été mal sélectionné c'est ce que
vous nous
dit d'une sélectionner les regarde on a
fait ils ont fait la même chose en
algérie on a essayé de former les imams
en algérie on veut dire c'est un pays
musulman à la base on peut le comprendre
mais en france on a en plus je vais vous
demander comment c'est la formation des
imams
la formation des imams c'est un document
qu'on vous donne vous parle des valeurs
de la république mais à l'imam il est
avant tout religieux
il va d'abord faire ce qu'il va lire
d'abord le coran avant de venir la
chartre on va lui donner mais ce
maquereau quelqu'un d'autre alors formé
et en plus il faut faire les formateurs
moi j'ai vu les gens qui forment les
mêmes ils sont toujours dans dans la
religion on et on les forme pas ils
n'ont pas un truc où c'est la république
et tout ça c'est qu'on dit la formation
des imams
je voudrais savoir qu on dans le
document c'est quoi le programme de la
formation la formation de ckoi c'est ce
que tu as le droit de dire ce que tu
manges melli même quand même dans
l'affairé la mosquée il est libre et
disent qu'ils veulent puisque c'est lui
qui fait les prêches et tout le monde
est libre de d'écouter cet imam ou de
panique alors moi la formation des imams
et des plutôt surveiller et inspectés
comme on inspecte à l'éducation
nationale un enseignant en eps a
inspecté les mêmes il faut arrêtez
arrêtez avec l'islam de france
il faut effectivement que sont tous
républicains nous avons tous les mêmes
droits on peut pas dire d'un côté on
veut former l'islam et d'un côté ses
relais séparatisme et d'un côté vouloir
former les imams ça veut dire moi je
pense que c'est contradictoire après
peut-être que je me trompe mais moi je
pense qu'on attend comme tout le monde
comme tous les français
merci beaucoup autre canal hier et
maintenant d'avoir été avec nous nous
avoir apporté votre analyse après le
discours d' emmanuel macron à mulhouse
merci à vous aussi
une centaine de médecins alertent sur
les conditions de détention de julian
assange dans un document publié dans une
revue médicale britannique il regrette
que le lanceur d alerte n'est pas accès
aux soins alors qu'approche une échéance
capitale pour lui de 24 février
il comparaîtra à londres en vue de son
extradition aux etats-unis les
précisions de rania berrada
ce ne sont pas moins de 117 médecins de
18 pays qui tire la sonnette d'alarmé
dans une lettre publiée ce lundi par la
revue britannique de l'enset ces
professionnels de la santé estime que
julian assange et sujet je cite à une
torture psychologique
il regrette que son droit fondamental à
des soins appropriés soient dénier
depuis que les médecins ont commencé à
examiner monsieur assange à l'ambassade
de l'équateur en 2015
les avis médicaux d'experts et les
recommandations urgente des médecins ont
toujours été ignorés
d'après les signataires les charges qui
pèsent contre le lanceur dallaire ne
doivent pas justifier ce qu'ils estiment
être une maltraitance
cette politisation des principes
médicaux fondamentaux nous préoccupe
profondément car elle a des implications
au delà du cas de julian assange
la maltraitance par négligence médicale
motivés par la politique crée un
dangereux précédent
compromettant en fin de compte
l'impartialité de notre profession
l'engagement pour la santé pour tous et
l'obligation de ne pas nuire
cette politisation du cas assange est
aussi au coeur des préoccupations de ses
soutiens lors d'une conférence organisée
ce mardi à londres
le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks a
estimé que cette affaire est aussi l'une
des attaques les plus graves contre le
journalisme ces dernières années
j'ai eu le privilège d'examiner
certaines pièces qui seront présentées à
la cour par les avocats de la défense de
julian dans mon esprit il ne fait aucun
doute l'absolument ans aucun doute qu'il
existe des arguments écrasant contre
cette demande d'extradition
si c'était une affaire qui était
simplement juger en vertu des lois
je ne m'inquièterai pas du tout mais
c'est un cas politique et ce qui est en
jeu ici ce n'est pas seulement la vie de
julian assange qui risquent 175 ans de
prison s'il est extradé
c'est l'avenir du journalisme voilà quel
point cette affaire est importante
il s'agit de l'attaqué la plus grave
contre le journalisme dans le monde ces
derniers temps depuis son arrestation en
avril 2019 à l'ambassade d'équateur
julian assange est détenu à la prison de
belmarsh dans le sud de londres
le lanceur d'alert doit comparaître le
24 février en vue de son extradition
vers les etats-unis et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis san
francisco aux états unis avec nos amis
iyaz journaliste auteur de wikileaks le
quatrième pouvoir l'histoire en marche
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir nozomi iyaz merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors cette
lettre des médecins la pétition de
journalistes de reporters sans
frontières
hier est ce que selon vous cela peut
peser avoir un impact sur le destin de
julian assange
parce qu'il est important pour la
communauté internationale de comprendre
que les droits de julien à singes ont
été volés par de nombreux que dans les
occidentaux notamment par le running
julien assange n'a pas accès à des soins
médicaux a déclaré
il a également été soumis à des tortures
psychologiques selon le rapport du
spécialiste de l'ogn nice mais ça donc
c'est très important que les d'auteur et
j'ai toutes les personnes qui se
préoccupent des droits de l'homme adopte
une position ferme
comment expliquer parce que les termes
très forts effectivement parle de
torture psychologique ont décrit une
privation de lumière de soins médicaux
de contact avec le monde extérieur
une situation qui a duré plus d'un an
comment on explique les droits les plus
élémentaires dans des démocraties n'ait
pas été respectée sur la personne de
julian assange comment vous l'expliquez
vous qui connaissez extrêmement bien ce
dossier julien assange régiment était
placé à tancer récemment conclus jusqu'à
tout récemment et le confinement
solitaire et reconnue au niveau
international comme en forme de torture
la pause d'autre part les militaires a
indiqué à que j'ai reprise que julien
assange a montré le preuve d'une
personne les signes d'une personne qui a
été torturé il est ex président pour les
experts pour les spécialistes que je lis
un sage a bien été torturé mais comment
justement l'expliqué encore une fois
dans des démocraties où l'on respecte le
théoriquement est normalement le les
droits de l'homme les plus élémentaires
comment expliquer cela
replacé situation dans le contexte
ce journaliste a révélé des documents
gouvernementaux concernant les actions
des états unis dans des théâtres de
guerre et sans être inculpés il a été
mis dans une prison gars de sécurité
maximum à londres donc effectivement
cela pose des questions et traitera
normalement deuxième démocratie un
journaliste ne serez jamais soumis un
tel traitement
effectivement cela montre que nous ne
pouvons pas vraiment tenté société
démocratique n'a t'on pas vraiment la
démocratie
nous n'avons pas la possibilité de faire
appel face à de telles violations des
lois l'audience approche au lundi 24
février une demande d'extradition
les états unis j'ai une haine assange
risque vraiment lourd
à quoi faut-il s'attendre selon vous les
juges devraient reconnaître que ce cas
que cette affaire à du tgs politique
qu'il n'y a pas de raisons légales et
que cause légale pour continuer le
processus d'extradition
j'espère dès que la première journée de
cette audition qui durera plusieurs
jours la sphère sera abandonnée et
julien assange sera libéré est ce que
vous pensez justement que cette pression
médiatique les journalistes et pétitions
des médecins peut peser sur ce procès
est ce que c'est un procès selon vous
qui va se tenir dans des conditions
sereines et est réellement indépendante
je pense que c'est vraiment ici qu'on va
voir s'ils vivent dans une société juste
pas et pour les personnes qui
s'intéressent à l'avenir du journalisme
il va falloir prêté beaucoup d'attention
à cette audience il commence la semaine
prochaine parce que cela nous permettra
de voir si nous vivons dans une société
démocratique ou pas le régime le
gouvernement britannique va pas pouvoir
faire exercice de son indépendance
juridique existait aux intérêts
américains et il est très clair que
cette affaire sera une preuve
un témoignage afin de savoir s'il vivons
pas dans une société démocratique
et si le royaume uni peut respecter ses
propres idées
cela signifiera la fin de notre état de
droit merci beaucoup nozomi aya
journaliste auteur de wikileaks le
quatrième pouvoir l'histoire en marche
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france la crise en libye à présent les
forces daf tard ont attaqué aujourd'hui
le port de tripoli pendant ce temps là a
eu lieu à genève la reprise des
négociations militaires ont fait le
point avec les îles à saraf le port
maritime de tripoli la cible d'une
attaque provenant des forces du maréchal
khalifa haftar une colonne de fumée
épaisse visible dans la direction de la
zone portuaire un entrepôt aurait été
touché alors que la situation sur le
terrain reste une situation où la trêve
est très fragile et de nouvelles
attaques ont lieu aujourd'hui dans le
port de tripoli où des incidents se
produisent un peu partout
la situation ne change pas nos bas
personne n'a jusqu'à présent renier le
principe d' acceptation de la trêve le
processus politique qui essaie de
trouver un moyen d'aller de l'avant ce
mardi les négociations de la commission
militaire mixte sur la libye ont donc
repris à genève dans un contexte tendu
la veille l'union européenne a sacrifié
la mission de surveillance lance en 2015
au large de la libye
une nouvelle est programmée
prochainement pour empêcher les
livraisons d'armes aux deux camps qui
s'affrontent dans le pays
le nom sofia faudrait
ça n'existe plus donc nous avons quand
même tour et un accord politique
un agrément politique sur le futur pense
que nous avons tous commenté c'est
formidable on est maintenant sur le
niveau de des nations unies est simple
aller dans la bonne direction
tripoli est depuis près d'un an la cible
d'une offensive lancée par l'armée
nationale libyenne
seul un accord pour un cessez le feu
stable garantirait la tenue du sommet
politique prévue le 26 février prochain
en grèce des milliers personnes sont en
grève et battre le pavé contre un projet
de réforme des retraites également comme
en france les transports sont très
impactées dans la capitale et services
publics également cecily à chaumont pour
les détails pas touche système de
sécurité sociale dix mille manifestants
rien que dans la capitale et sur leurs
banderoles
un appel général à sauvegarder l'état
providence
le déclencheur un projet gouvernemental
de réforme des retraites qui doit être
voté avant la fin de la semaine au
parlement
tout va de mal en pis
les retraites seront à un niveau
inférieur et ne seront pas en mesure de
respecter des obligations
c'est la chose la plus importante en
décembre 2018 des centaines de grecs
s'étaient mobilisés en soutien au
mouvement français des gilets jaunes
beaucoup de syndicalistes mais aussi
toutes sortes de membres de la société
civile qui partagent le même combat
nous comptons sur notre pays pour
couvrir notre système de santé et
subvenir à nos besoins
quand nous serons vieux c est tout cela
semble être mis en doute à présent
conséquences de la crise financière de
2008 la grèce applique une stricte
politique d'austérité comme en france
les grévistes les plus nombreux
appartiennent aux services publics mais
pas seulement
des journalistes ont observé un arrêt de
travail de trois heures en début
d'après-midi près donc quelques instants
rester avec nous reviendrons sur la
réforme des retraites début de l'examen
des amendements à l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui trois semaines de débats
intenses en perspective et puis nous
resterons enfants sont des trains à
hydrogène pourrait bien arriver d'ici
trois ou quatre ans selon le p dg
d'alstom a
[Musique]
il cherche sa mère cette petite boule
d'amour n'aurait aucune chance de
survivre dans la nature
les pandas mères ne peuvent élever qu'un
seul bébé à la fois les elle donne
naissance à deux bébés chaque année la
chine met beaucoup d'efforts pour
compenser cette erreur cruel de la
nature cela veut dire quels thèmes
vierge elle fait ce sont en chine
l'élevage des pandas effet à la chaîne
c'est comme si on les tire avec une
imprimante 3d pour les présenter au
public par la suite en 2016 le panda a
été retiré de la liste des espèces en
voie de disparition
cette espèce n'est plus menacée mais
reste vulnérable mais tout ce travail de
scientifiques dévoué sera inutile si les
pandas ne peuvent pas se reproduire en
captivité
ce n'est pas qu'ils veulent s'abstenir
les pandas deviennent amoureux avec la
même part est ce qu ils font tout le
reste
cette firmament a donné naissance à des
jumeaux et n'a aucune idée qu'une potion
d'amour spéciale a été formulée juste
pour elle
[Musique]
allez en l'air a pas de bruit en
tournant est fermée poil talons
[Musique]
pied droit tu dirige vers des coulisses
pham hùng
il était vraiment curieux de voir ce
qu'il rencontrerait ce fameux disque
arrêter ce qui compte quand on entre en
scène c'était le premier pas
ce jour là nous avons dansé ri lac des
cygnes
c'est très difficile pour moi en tant
que soliste du coup je mal à cause de
pointe
sinon on pourrait faire un malaise à
cause de la douleur le lac des cygnes
est un spectacle est très compliqué cela
veut dire qu'ils doivent danser à
l'unisson nous ne quittons presque pas
la scène seulement pour se changer cela
nous épuise physiquement et mentalement
[Applaudissements]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eu
aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement vrai besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi on a vu la serre les
plantes ou fait de vivre avec les
plantes comme ça vraiment commune comme
une machine un organisme pour fait
partie de cette île de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on
construisait cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout
petit voici les types de l'actualité de
ce mardi
deuxième journée d'examen de la réforme
des retraites à l'assemblée nationale
après des échanges parfois houleux les
députés se sont attaqués aujourd'hui aux
milliers d'amendements d opposition
alors que dans le même temps s'ouvrait
le conflit conférence de financement en
présence des partenaires sociaux
lutter contre toutes manifestations du
séparatisme islamistes emmanuel macron
en visite à mulhouse nous a dévoilé une
partie de son plan de bataille
parmi les annonces que l'on retiendra le
chef de l'état qui indique son souhait
de mettre fin au système des imams des
tâches est envoyé en france par d'autres
pays
et puis sa volonté de favoriser
l'organisation du culte musulman
[Musique]
deuxième jour de débats donc sur la
réforme des retraites pour les députés
au menu les amendements déposés par
l'opposition ils sont très nombreux plus
de 40000 déposé en majorité par les
insoumis et des communistes
une journée de travail chargée donc mais
aussi houleuse
on retrouve l assemblée nationale notre
reporter guillemin rossi bonsoir
guillemin qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir
de cette deuxième journée de débats à
l'assemblée nationale eh bien stéphanie
ce que l'on peut retenir c'est que le
travail parlementaire de l'examen des
amendements a enfin commencé de cours de
cette première séance qui s'est terminée
à 21 une seconde séance doit d'ailleurs
débuté à 21h30 les premiers donc
d'amendements ont été examinés les
premiers des 40 2000 plus de 40000 vous
l'avais dit à 1 42 mille amendements si
l'on prend en compte les deux textes les
deux projets de loi ordinaire et
organique est en réalité on en est au
tout début tout début de ce texte en
réalité on n'en est même pas au début du
texte on en est encore au titre de cette
de cette réforme puisque c'était bien le
titre que concerner les dernières les
derniers les derniers amendements
examinés au cours de cette première
séance
alors au delà de ce travail de fourmi
qui comptent entamer les députés
aujourd'hui les plusieurs annonces de
fait notamment par le le
le président de l'assemblée nationale
qui a fixé le quai le cadre des débats
tout d'abord sur les délais dont va
disposer l'assemblée nationale une
troisième c1 en une troisième semaine
pardon de débat a été ajoutée avec des
travaux qui seront suspendus
le 6 mars pour les élections municipales
et ensuite richard ferrand a également
pris une disposition considérant que la
france insoumise et le parti communiste
faisait obstruction fait une obstruction
parlementaire du fait du nombre du trop
grand nombre d'amendements similaires
déposées il a réduit le temps de parole
il a limité le nombre de prises de
parole à un orateur seulement pour
chacun de ces deux groupes une décision
qui a bien entendu été vivement critiqué
par l'opposition mais qui compte bien
poursuivre sa stratégie je vous propose
de l'écouter m'ont dit tous d'accord que
cette réforme est mal ficelé n'est pas
clair elle et elle est incompréhensible
et en fait elle va détruire les
retraites des français voilà la réalité
vous comprenez plus ça va vite - les
français soient au courant de ce qui se
trame de ce qu'il ya derrière et nous
notre rôle c'est d'être les porte voix
des français donc plus c'est long plus
le gouvernement va perdre des plumes et
plus les français vont dire aux députés
en marge mais comment vous pouvez voter
ça
l'objectif c'est on sait qu'ici ça peut
passer ils ont la majorité pour ça d'une
manière ou d'une autre
maintenant il faut que ça passe dans la
douleur et pas que ça passe comme dans
du beurre c'est l'objectif donc il faut
que ils le traînent leur projet ils
n'avaient qu'à pas le passé en procédure
accélérée il n'avait qu'à nous donner du
temps on était supposé lire ça en trois
jours bon voilà donc
qu'on ne nous dise pas que c'est
nécessaire de passer ça avant les
municipales en avait déjà blackrock qui
félicité le gouvernement en disant ce
que vous faites c'est très bien mais là
on a lampert la plus grande association
de d'assurer d'accord qui en fait est
liée à que ça aussi et qui dit
maintenant une chose est sûre se
constituer à titre individuel un
complément de retraite en vue de ses
vieux jours va devenir inévitable pour
compenser la baisse annoncée des
pensions de retraite voilà la vérité
c'est donc une guerre d'usure qui se
déroule ici au palais bourbon entre d'un
côté le gouvernement et la majorité et
de l'autre côté l'opposition une guerre
d'usure qui pourrait bien tourner court
aujourd'hui le nouveau ministre de la
santé olivier verrons a laissé entendre
que le recours aux 49 3 n'était pas
exclue même si noter même si ce n'était
pas à l'ordre du jour actuellement
merci neymar aussi en direct de
l'assemblée nationale et dans le même
temps à la conférence de financement a
débuté aujourd'hui objectif ramener l
équilibre le système de retraite d'ici à
les organisations syndicales et
patronales ont jusqu'à fin avril pour
trouver une solution alternative à
l'instauration d'un h pivot de 64 ans
est ce matin devant le ministère des
solidarités de la santé cyril chez
besnier président de la cftc s'est
montré optimiste
ça sera difficile puisqu'on n'est pas
tous d'accord sur le principe même de la
de la réforme comme venait de le répéter
mais je pense qu'on a un véritable enjeu
on doit on doit réussir à se mettre
d'accord à trouver un compromis je pense
que c'est peut-être un peu la dernière
chance pour montrer que le dialogue
social dans ce pays peut aboutir un
consensus à un compromis
si on n'y arrive pas je pense qu'on a le
risque de donner du grain à moudre à
ceux qui pensent que cela violence peut
arriver à obtenir des résultats
donc je pense qu'on a vraiment
un très très gros enjeu en tout cas pour
l'accepter c'est on nous fera tout pour
qu'on puisse aboutir à cette conférence
mais à condition encore une fois que
l'effort soit équilibre en parler nous
sommes avec denis barbarossa experts
comptables co fondateur d'à complice
bonsoir dénis et barbarossa merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
vous les experts comptables vous avez
fait votre propre étude d'impact les
résultats finaux seront dévoilés en mars
2020 est ce que vous avez déjà une
première voilà impression à la lumière
de cette étude
bonsoir aujourd'hui on a effectivement
une grosse inquiétude on a
commencé à chiffrer a essayé de poser
beaucoup de questions puisqu'on était
assez intrigué par les promesses
gouvernementales beaucoup de gagnants
assez peu de perdants théoriquement
quand on commence à assimiler un petit
peu différemment on se rend compte qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de perdre en tout
cas chez indépendant et on a eu beaucoup
de 2,2 des changes avec le gouvernement
ce qui nous a effectivement poussé à
lancer cette étude au niveau de la
qu'avec votre caisse de retraite lac
avec a souhaité lancer une étude pour
mieux comprendre avec six autres caisses
de retraite de professions libérales
pour challenger un petit peu les études
lancées par le gouvernement et
comprendre comment autant de gagnants
pouvait coûter aussi cher en fait dans
un régime qui se voulait équilibré dans
une promesse de coût identique pour le
concitoyen est donc premier peut-être
premières impressions de ces études où
rien n'a filtré pour l'instant encore de
filtres effectivement sur le sujet donc
les spécialistes se sont réunies on
commença à devrait également des
consoeurs et confrères en fait experts
comptables ont demandé en fait à pouvoir
contribuer à apporter leur pierre à
l'édifice que je salue c'est une très
bonne initiative que vouloir rester bon
contribuer aux côtés des spécialistes
une fois encore on est quand même
dubitatif en fait sur le sur le mode de
financement puisque on a de nouvelles
promesses notamment d'un minimum
vieillesse très fortement augmenté
ça ne se fait pas sans son coût
complémentaire en tout cas sans
cotisation complémentaire donc sans
revenus diminuer pour ceux qui cotisent
aujourd'hui alors votre indignation de
la part des experts comptables mais pas
que évidemment le parlement qui vote
aujourd'hui de texte mais finalement
sans savoir combien cela va coûter
c'est à dire que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui vous nous guide ou n'a
aucune idée
vraiment de ce que ça va coûter
complètement concrètement à une étude
d'impact qui fait plus de 1000 pages
aujourd'hui qui ne permet pas à tout un
chacun de prendre la mesure en fait des
enjeux avec beaucoup de simulations
beaucoup de chiffres qui ont été
communiqués
des chiffres une fois encore qu'ils ne
nous paraissent pas cohérent tout cas le
peu que nous avons testé sur ce qui nous
concerne démontre que les chiffres
effectivement d'étude d'impact ne sont
pas tout à fait juste et cohérent donc
il est quand même compliquée aujourd'hui
je pense pour un députés de se prononcer
sur un texte aussi engageant il n'engage
pas que la majorité actuelle et le
gouvernement actuel il engage que même
la profession et la france et nos
concitoyens sur les 40 prochaines années
pour les cotisants et 20 ans de retraite
ces cas là un enjeu très important de
peau pâle pandala gers et 14% du pib ces
360 milliards d'euros de dépenses
ça ne suppose quand même ça suppose un
minimum de travaux et d'études
préalables alors vous vous avez aussi un
cours ou au personnel un chez les
experts comptables vous cotisez déjà
pour un régime particulier mais vous
devrez également cotiser pour ce régime
universel l'instar un petit peu d des
avocats où en est votre combat ce que
vous êtes entendus par le gouvernement
entendu on l'est tous aujourd'hui je
pense que gouvernement effectivement
fait preuve d'une entente certaines donc
il reçoit beaucoup il est il entend
jeunesse voilà il y aller c'est tout le
débat on déplore en fait un nombre d'
écoute de la part du gouvernement qui
effectivement reçoit nous entend
mais n'écoute pas en tant que tel les
débats que nous pouvons avoir joué les
craintes de la profession
ces craintes sont justifiées aujourd'hui
on a assimilé aujourd'hui des coûts très
largement supplémentaires je les ai déjà
dit à votre antenne la semaine d'années
on a 20 % d'augmentation de nos
cotisations minimum et 10% de réduction
delà de nos pensions ce qui est
effectivement un sujet très important
nous cotisons déjà à la société
nationale donc nous cotisons de l'ordre
de 100 millions d'euros pour la
profession d'expert-comptable donc vingt
mille personnes cotisent au niveau déjà
de la solidarité pour des sommes assez
importantes
nous ne sommes pas contre un régime
universel le régime de points nous
sommes déjà dedans donc c'est un système
que l'on connaît qui a l'avantagé
vêtements de sa simplicité pour tout à
chacun de comprendre combien le stock de
points est acquis et donc quelle est sa
valeur pour eux pour demain le problème
de fond c'est qu'on n'a pas la valeur du
point aujourd'hui
les prévisions sur sur des bases
complètement incertaine on ne sait pas
comment évaluera évoluera ce point
puisque en fait on a entendu lire la
semaine dernière que finalement on verra
bien nouvel indice arriver et nous
sommes effectivement très circonspect
sur la méthodologie aujourd'hui et la
durabilité en fait de cette cette voie
ces inquiétudes voulait formule est
évidemment puisqu'on vous le dit vous
êtes entendu qu est ce qu on vous répond
concrètement quand on vous avez une
personne en face qui représente le
gouvernement elle vous dit quoi
il faut être solidaire nous sommes déjà
qu'il faut prendre le courage d'avoir
des réformes ambitieuses pour nos
concitoyens et solidaire une fois encore
la réforme sans aucun doute une fois
encore nous sommes pour la réforme mais
ne sommes pas pour cette forme de
réformes qui nous paraît pas tout à fait
plausible aujourd'hui absolument pas
chiffré ce qui nous pose un véritable
sujet nous faut encore vu les enjeux
importants et et surtout trop trop mal
préparés en fait concrètement alors on a
entendu évidemment beaucoup de
professions se manifester les danseuses
et les danseurs de l'opéra de paris les
avocats
vous êtes plutôt une profession assez
discrète quels sont vos moyens
d'attendre pour d'actions par donc on
vous faire entendre et surtout écouter
c'est tout le sujet la profession qui
effectivement a finalement c'est peu de
moyens de pression aujourd'hui à
linverse de nos amis avocats que je
salue pour leur courage et leur
engagement
nous n'avons pas de lieux comme le
palais pour nous retrouver et sert
caisse de résonance nous avons une
mission d'intérêt général d'une mission
légale également que de respecter et
faire respecter la loi donc on ne peut
pas se permettre de ne pas faire de
déclarations pour le compte de nos
clients
par contre effectivement certains
commencent déjà aujourd'hui à émettre le
souhait de revenir une déclaration
papier à revenir également aux tchèques
pourquoi pas pour freiner en fait
l'encaissement et gêner un petit peu la
tutelle c'est ça fait parti d'un d'un
des propositions qu'on peut entendre ici
et là on voit ce une profession
effectivement assez citoyenne et et
droite dans la volonté de servir et
continuer à rester au service certes de
l'état puisque nous sommes une
profession sous tutelle mais deux
clients avant tout qu'ils restent nos
donneurs d'ordres pour vous aujourd'hui
la mobilisation elle va ce jouer ou sur
le terrain comme on l'a vu en décembre
avec des blocages du pays notamment dans
les transports elle va se jouer au
parlement c'est que ça s'annonce assez
compliquée avec voilà ces milliers et
milliers plus de 40 mille amendements
quelle peut être l'issue pour vous je
n'ai pas de boule de cristal et je suis
encore moins on commet députés donc j'ai
pas la la la la
l'oreille aujourd'hui et la capacité en
fait à comprendre qu'il peut comment
aujourd'hui que vivent ce bouleversement
très important que nos concitoyens donc
ont vécu et que la france aujourd'hui
avec une pile comme de nombreux mois ce
que nous demandons tout cas nos
consoeurs et confrères
c'est d'informer très massivement
notamment les députés pour leur faire
prendre conscience des enjeux de la
réforme et conscience des risques
aujourd'hui qui pèsent sur cette réforme
nous avons déjà un modèle de courrier
que notre monde syndical ifec institut
français d expert comptable et
commissaire aux comptes a communiqué à
ma profession pour faire en sorte que
massivement la profession se mobilise et
écrivent à ses députés pour leur faire
prendre conscience des enjeux c'est pour
nous jouer le meilleur le meilleur atout
clé de faire prendre conscience aux
députés de l'importance des textes qui
sont sous les yeux aujourd'hui et de
l'incohérence de certaines de certains
chiffres comment vous avez réagi au
départ de la ministre bus ça change bien
finalement pour vous c'est plutôt un
mauvais signal c'est un sujet complexe
les retraites il est complexe de se
mettre dans ce sujet aussi lourd aussi
aussi important d'un point de vue
mathématique d'une part et d'engagement
pour le pour la préfète pour le pour
l'état un changement ce moment sur les
sujets aussi lourd n'est pas évident
sans aucun doute même si le secrétaire
d'état en fait c'est tout son travail
sur son sujet en tant que tel les enjeux
de la ministre était important et il me
paraît crucial dans ces cas là de mettre
au moins en sommeil la retraite la
réforme pendant le temps que chacun
puisse effectivement retrouvé un petit
peu ses marques et prend le temps d'une
vraie discussion il ya eu le temps de la
concertation qui était plutôt un temps
d'écouté de la part de nos gouvernants
il serait peut-être temps maintenant
d'aller vraiment dans le dur du sujet de
comprendre que les français sont
inquiets sur cette réforme et que les
professions libérales également sont
très inquiètes des propositions qui ont
été faites et qui ne tiennent pas compte
une fois encore de ce que l' ocde
propose
nous avons aujourd'hui beaucoup de
propositions pertinent de la part de nos
voisins européens la france se fait
toujours fort de vouloir innover
différemment on a su innover en 50 à 4
tva est un impôt que le monde nous envie
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire que la
formule soit un impôt on serait qu'une
réforme que se sont vus quand on voit
les résultats dans la rue merci beaucoup
de nibards barça d'avoir été avec nous
alstom annonce le rachat de la branche
ferroviaire de son rival canadien
bombardier l'occasion pour la société
française de devenir le numéro 2
du secteur le rachat devrait avoisiner 6
milliards d'euros mais il n'interviendra
pas avant une validation de la
commission européenne est précisément
dylan afférents dian avec cyrielle
l'abbé david hess bullion une sacrée
revanche seulement un an après l'échec
de la fusion alstom siemens
le fabricant ferroviaire s'offre son
concurrent canadien ce lundi après
plusieurs semaines de rumeurs autour du
projet le p dg d'alstom a annoncé la
signature d'un protocole d'accord pour
acheter bombardier transport montant de
la transaction de 5,8 à 6,2 milliards
d'euros l'occasion pour le fabricant du
tgv de doubler de volume et mieux
affronter une concurrence de plus en
plus vives
cette acquisition renforcera notre
présence internationale ainsi que notre
capacité à répondre à la demande
toujours plus importante de solutions de
mobilité durable
bombardier transport apportera à alstom
une complémentarité géographique et
industriels sur des marchés en
croissance
ainsi que des plateformes technologiques
additionnel
les parts de l'entreprise serait divisé
la caisse de dépôt et placement du
québec détiendrait 18 % les parts de
bouygues passerait de 15 % à 10 % et
alstom disposerait du solde du capital
mais une étape primordiale reste à venir
la validation du projet par la
commission européenne margret des stages
heures commissaire européenne en charge
de la concurrence et bruno le maire
ministre français de l'économie et des
finances s'entretiendront ce mardi à ce
sujet à bruxelles
je me réjouis qu'alstom à travers
l'acquisition de bombardier transport
jouent un rôle de premier plan dans le
renforcement de l'industrie ferroviaire
européenne
ce renforcement est plus que jamais une
priorité compte tenu des besoins
croissants en mobilité durable la
transaction est prévue pour le premier
trimestre 2001 21
si elle est une bonne nouvelle pour le
français elle représente aussi un
nouveau souffle pour le groupe canadien
qui était depuis quelques années en
difficulté financière et pour
l'économiste philippe muray re le rachat
de bombardier est un joli coup même si
aujourd'hui la france selon lui n'a pas
de véritable politique industrielle par
rapport à l'opération alstom siemens
aussi mince
avec des capitaux allemand racheté
alstom avec tous les risques de
délocalisation d'usinés et d'emplois là
c'est un joli coup en plus c'est une
opération équilibrée
ce sont deux entreprises relativement
saine qu'on le même chiffre d'affaires
alstom va garder les usines à au canada
et aussi en france
thil qui l'ont donc c'est une opération
intéressante équilibrée avec un petit
point de détail quand même c'est que les
québécois et le gouvernement du québec a
fait très attention il prend 18 % du
capital du nouvel ensemble
alstom bombardier pour que les usines
restent bien au québec et ça il faudrait
que la france fasse la même chose
reprennent la part de bruit qui veut
sortir de alstom pour que la france ait
aussi des parts et pèse autant il faut
pas qu alstom bombardier deviennent
canadien le pdg a expliqué qu'il y avait
pas de redondance et donc qui aurait pas
de pertes d'emplois
les deux entreprises sont
complémentaires en termes de zones
géographiques et donc a priori ya pas de
redondance et il n'y a pas de souci
là-dessus
la sainte concurrence et la bible de
l'union européenne mais en fait un vrai
on peut regarder l'opération de cette
manière là en gros alstom bombardier
fera 15 milliard de chiffre d'affaires
alors que serre c'est le chinois fait 30
milliards de chiffre d'affaires 30
milliards d'euros
donc si on dit alstom bombardier n'a pas
le droit de se créer parce que ça
poserait un problème de concurrence
ça veut dire que le chinois n'a pas le
droit de vendre chez nous parce que ça
poserait un problème de concurrence
aussi est sûre crois que c'est là dessus
que le gouvernement français doit se
défendre en expliquant que voilà en plus
de cela il ya autre chose c'est que le
chinois à 30 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en chine est en fait
principalement en chine il a tous ses
marchés publics ils sont réservés à lui
donc pourquoi ouvrir le marché européen
du rail qui est réservée qui devrait
être réservé aux européens
pourquoi l'ouvrir aux chinois alors
qu'eux mêmes se réservent leur marché
une absence de réciprocité une naïveté
qui pose un vrai problème
et dernière chose l'union européenne a
les cirages clé
racheter le fabricant de locomotives
vosloo par cette boîte qui fait 30
milliards de chiffre d'affaires
donc ça pose et ils n'ont pas trouvé
problème là dessus il faut qu'elle soit
cohérente la commission européenne si
elle veut pas que
elle peut dire effectivement on veut pas
de fusion et symbian dans ce cas là on
fait pas rentrer crc sur notre marché
ça c'est très important et serein tout
ça ça va avoir un impact
moi je pense très important pour la
transition écologique parce qu'il faut
savoir que alstom
en fait est le premier constructeur qui
a mis un train à hydrogène sur les rails
et il en a vendu une trentaine à
l'allemagne il y en a déjà un qui
fonctionne ce qu'on pourrait faire
c'est que toutes les locomotives diesel
il y en a encore beaucoup en france tout
le réseau est pas lectrices y ait sur
les petites lignes notamment tous ces
locomotives diesel pour être remplacée
un grand plan à 5 10 ans par des
locomotives à hydrogène alstom avec un
intérêt très important c'est que ça
ferait croître l'écosystème hydrogène en
france où pour ensuite mettre les bus à
hydrogène dans toutes les villes comme
paris qui étouffe sous les particules
fines ou lyon est ensuite utilisé tout
cet écosystème pour aller beaucoup plus
loin pour aller travailler que nos
constructeurs automobiles pour mettre en
place des voitures à hydrogène des
scooters à hydrogène en france et là on
aurait on ferait politique industrielle
emploi transition écologique
je pense que tout le monde serait ravie
on est toujours en france les contrôles
fiscaux permettent chaque année à l'état
de récupérer des milliards d'euros en
2010 ce ne sont pas moins de neuf
milliards que le fisc a recouvré cela
représente environ un milliard de plus
qu'en 2018
les chiffres donnés hier par le premier
ministre et loire philippe lors d'une
conférence de presse à bercy
en 2019
l'état a encaissé 9 milliards d'euros
grâce aux contrôles fiscaux
sans compter les amendes pénales comme
dans le dossier google 9 milliards
d'euros c'est l'équivalent madame la
garde des sceaux du budget du ministère
de la justice en fraudant on vole la
nation ont trahi sa confiance et celle
des citoyens qui s'acquittent de leurs
obligations
nous ne voulons aucun passe-droit aucune
indulgence juste la loi elle le
durcissement des contrôles fiscaux est
donc une réussite pour le premier
ministre au delà de la satisfaction
edouard philippe a fait savoir que de
nouvelles mesures allaient être prises
[Musique]
rétropédalage de l'union européenne les
vingt-sept font marche arrière
concernant les pesticides interdits des
pesticides jugés trop dangereux pour
être autorisé dans l'union européenne
mais qui finalement pourrait être à
nouveau tôt d'airé alors pourquoi
éléments de réponse avec david khalifa
santé ou commerces un choix cornélien
pour l'union européenne surtout quand on
parle d'agriculture mais pourtant on
semble plus privilégié la manne
financière engrangés par l'exportation
plutôt que la bonne santé des
consommateurs comme d'habitude ce sont
les pesticides le centre du problème des
pesticides jugés trop dangereux pour
être autorisé dans l'union européenne
qui pourrait finalement être toléré la
raison épargné le commerce international
une décision qui résulte de plusieurs
années de lobbying des fabricants
ajoutez à ça à des manoeuvres
diplomatiques d'un groupe d'une
quinzaine de pays etats unis et canada
en première ligne pour que bruxelles
cède du terrain dans sa propre
réglementation et ce rapport de l' ong
bruxelloise corporate europe observatory
publié ce lundi montre comment ces
pressions continuelles ont fait reculer
les responsables européens du simple
fonctionnaire au commissaire jusqu'à la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen a été fier
d'annoncer au monde un accord avec
donald trump à davos le mois dernier
nous avons eu de très bonnes discussions
le président américain et moi même ici à
davos et nous avons convenu un peu nous
voulions avancer rapidement
je pense que nous avons beaucoup en
commun beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles
il faut qu'on travaille nous
avons des problèmes à résoudre nous ne
devrions pas perdre trop de temps mais
s'asseoir et négocier immédiatement et
nous avons un processus de suivi dans
lequel on sera impliqué la législation
européenne bafouée pour pouvoir
favoriser les exportations étrangères et
ne pas contrarier l'oncle sam
voilà le topo pour aller plus en
profondeur du problème c'est un
pesticide obéissent ou obéissait à des
critères d'exclusion précis dit
guillotine en d'autres termes une
interdiction automatique des pesticides
qui seront jugés intrinsèquement
dangereux
au moment de leur évaluation ou
réévaluation et ils sont plutôt nombreux
outre atlantique
un quart des pesticides employés aux
états unis plus précisément sont
interdits en europe
parmi eux le pesticides tueurs
d'abeilles
ce texte adopté en 2018 par les états
membres après des années de négociations
va donc être réévaluée au grand dam du
commissaire européen à la santé en
charge de ce dossier pour lequel il
s'est longuement battu
je suis heureux que les états membres
aient voté en faveur de notre
proposition d'aller plus loin dans la
restriction de l'utilisation des
substances actives imidaclopride
clothianidine et thiaméthoxam connu sous
le nom de néonicotinoïdes les
gouvernements ne soient évidemment pas
les seuls à mettre la pression sur
l'union européenne depuis 2010 est les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
un en particulier bayer n'hésite pas à
remettre en question toutes ces
interdictions et pour cela ils tentent
de faire jouer la corde sensible en
allant directement se plaindre auprès du
cabinet du commissaire à la santé
bayer s'inquiète du fait que cela
n'affecterait pas seulement ses
activités dans lieux mais aussi dans les
pays tiers s'exportant envers lieu le
cpa l'organisation européenne de
lobbying du secteur pharmaceutique est
aussi largement responsables de ce
soudain recul de nos européenne à
l'automne 2007 un rapport avance que les
importations agricoles seraient touchés
à hauteur de 70 milliards d'euros avec
ces restrictions
alors que l'union européenne applique
les critères de coupure basée sur les
risques pour les substances actives
utilisées dans les produits de
protection des cultures la perte
éventuelle de limites maximales de
résidus de pesticides a le potentiel de
nuire aux importations agricoles
valu à près de 70 milliards d'euros en
2016 au fil des trois dernières années
toutes ces pressions ont porté leurs
fruits si bien qu'en juillet 2019
l'union européenne est accusé à travers
un rapport remis à l'om c'est par une
quinzaine de pays d'essayer d'imposer
unilatéralement sa propre approche
réglementaire intérieur à ses
partenaires commerciaux
fin de citation bruxelles semble donc
dans l'impasse et va très certainement
sacrifiés au nom du commerce sa lutte
contre les pesticides dans quelques
instants rester avec nous notre débat
sur le plan de bataille et d'emmanuel
macron contre le séparatisme islamistes
et mesure arrive-t-elle trop tard sont
elles efficaces quelle est la première
impression on en débattra avec nos
invités
[Musique]
à
votre gouvernement et notre gouvernement
ainsi que tous les autres grands
gouvernements du monde savent ce qui va
se passer et quand ça va se passer
attendu mais ne vous ont pas dit et ils
ne me l'ont pas dit matt vous pouvez
imaginer quelque chose de si grands que
la terre faire ça cela va provoquer des
raz-de-marée et des tremblements de
terre les éruptions la terre la
s'incliner ça va être payant c'est le
club de mon grand père personne ne se
soucierait des lois ou d'aller en prison
illégalité prospérerait et la vie
deviendrait insupportable
[Musique]
ces séquences sont uniques car
habituellement les territoires tribaux
de zoé ne sont pas accessibles au public
eric peut s'y rendre parce que c'est le
médecin personnel de la tribu zoé
les gens disent ils le connaissent tout
simplement comme le docteur éric il est
riche célèbre et il est toujours en
mouvement
à la barre de yachts et d'aéronefs
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à croire que c'est là ma
famille
il n'y a pas de forêt
il est considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs neurochirurgien du brésil
[Musique]
ce qui se passe en amazonie c'est que
nos ressources sont exportées du brésil
il ne reste rien pour la population rien
ne revient à la population de l'amazonie
[Musique]
ah bon des femmes bon bien aimable ou
une femme ce qui a été l'histoire
jusqu'à maintenant était biaisé
[Musique]
à
oh
pour l'histoire de là d'ailleurs la
problématique est bien là pour
l'histoire de l'art c'est marginal et il
a fallu vraiment des femmes génial très
très doué pour arriver à trouver une
place dans un domaine où rien n'était
prévu pour elle
[Musique]
ces femmes artistes ne s'en sont sortis
que parce qu'elle avait les tripes
vraiment bien accroché
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre
emmanuel macron s'engage donc contre ce
qu'ils appellent le séparatisme
islamistes le chef de l'état était à
mulhouse aujourd'hui où il a affiché sa
volonté de lutter contre les
discriminations avec une république qui
doit tenir ses promesses at il dit il a
notamment présenté lors d'une conférence
de presse en fin d'après midi quatre
grands axes de son plan de lutte contre
le séparatisme dans la république
pour lui il est important de bien cerner
l'ennemi de la république qui est le
séparatisme et non le communautarisme ou
encore l'islam sujet sensible loin
d'accorder les différents camps
politiques
alors quand certains ont peur d'une
stigmatisation des musulmans d'autres
estiment que la lutte contre l'islam
politique est aujourd'hui une urgence en
france écoutez notre ennemi et à ce
titre le séparatisme c'est à dire ce
phénomène que nous observons depuis des
décennies qui est une volonté de quitter
la république ne plus en respecter les
règles d'un mouvement de repli qui en
raison de croyances et d'appartenance
vise à sortir du champ républicain est
ce que nous avons à faire mais pas comme
j'ai parfois entendu chez certains un
plan contre l'islam ce serait une faute
profonde
cette stratégie de lutte contre le
séparatisme islamistes elle doit se
construire un musée autour de quatre
lignes de force
la première c'est de reprendre le
contrôle et de lutter contre les
influences étrangères en particulier à
l'école et dans les lieux de culte c'est
ce sur quoi je veux surtout aujourd'hui
m'exprimer la deuxième c'est de
favoriser une meilleure organisation du
culte musulman en france justement dans
le respect de la laïcité et pour
s'assurer du respect de toutes les lois
de la troisième ligne de force et de
lutter avec détermination contre toutes
les manifestations du séparatisme
islamistes et du repli communautariste
qu'il génère et qui contreviennent aux
lois et règlements c'est à dire rentrer
dans le détail ce que je viens d'évoquer
et point par point là où la loi est
ambigu là où des pratiques se sont
développées pouvoir y répondre
beaucoup de calme et la quatrième ligne
de force c'est de pouvoir partout
ramener la république
là où elle a un peu démissionner où elle
n'a pas toujours été au rendez-vous ou
des difficultés sont apparues que nous
n'avons pas su résoudre comme il se
devait ces mesures d' emmanuel macron
sont elles à la hauteur at il trouvé les
mots peuvent elles être efficace c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pourront débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec anouar kbibech président du
rassemblement des musulmans de france
bonsoir noir qu'à me laisse merci d'être
avec nous à ses côtés également georges
cros - devich président de la république
souveraine bonsoir merci à vous
également d'être là alors on va
s'arrêter sur la sémantique parce que
manifestement c'était un aspect
extrêmement important de ce discours
attendu des manuels macron qui s'était
pas exprimé sur le sujet depuis un petit
moment
elle lutter contre le séparatisme
islamiste est ce que cette appellation
et j'avoue semble approprié anouar
kbibech effectivement enfin en parler
avant de communautarisme et
effectivement il ya qu une seule
communauté qui vaille c'est la
communauté nationale
par contre ça pouvait effectivement
prêter à confusion parce qu'il ya des
communautés et de langues des
communautés de religions diverses et
variées le mot séparation sépara
séparatisme et est encore plus fort
parce qu'il ya une notion de rupture de
rupture par rapport à la société de
rupture par rapport aux valeurs de la
république et qui n'est pas forcément
d'ordre religieux même si le président
de la république parle du séparatisme
d'origine islamiste mais je pense que la
notion de séparatistes ont peut être
peut s'appliquer à plusieurs autres
phénomènes qui peuvent être d'ordre
social économique est et pas seulement
religieux donc mettons une bonne chose
pour vous la réplication élevé
d'ambiguïté chargeant kossmann au vide
c'était important on attendait aussi sur
les mots on a parfois reproché au
président de ne pas nommer les choses
ça vous convient cette appellation elle
est approprié lui c'est de faire bref
non mais entendre dans les mots dans la
bouche du président la république
emmanuel macron le thème de séparatisme
moi me pose un problème un problème
parce que et il fait partie d'une caste
économique qui est la première à séparer
de la plus française en détruisant le
socle national sur lequel repose notre
pays depuis le congrès national de la
résistance et je pense à tout ce qui
fait la solidarité nationale on le voit
récemment encore avec cette réforme de
retraites qui va passer en force contre
l'ensemble du peuple et contre le
conseil y compris contre le conseil
d'état donc là on a un véritable
séparatisme qui renvoie aux travaux de
l'américain christopher lasch qui
parlait de trahison des élites on a une
caste qui trahi son peuple
jusqu'à lui retirer massivement l arrêté
massivement comme ça a été le cas avec
les gilet jaune
maintenant effectivement il y à un
courant de l'islam politique radicale
qui est séparatiste en france et
ailleurs je rappelle qu'il frappe
d'abord les pays de religion ou de
culture musulmane en premier avant les
pays occidentaux mais ce sont des gens
qui ont une ce sont des politiques sont
des gens qui ont une vision politique et
religieuse globale et qui sont en guerre
totale contre tous ceux qui ont une
autre vision
donc en france effectivement il faut les
combattre par par tous les moyens
mais moi je préfère quand même parler de
communautarisme parce que c'est un terme
qui est entendu accepté par tous et là
il ya quand même un souci de la part d'
emmanuel macron parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est influencer
considérablement et dans bien des
domaines par les états unis où on a le
monde anglo saxon c'est un monde
communautariste et on l'a bien vu avec
dans bien des cas avec ce gouvernement
et madame belloubet qui est qui a eu du
mal sur la ferme il a commencé à parler
à ma part de faire de blasphème massy en
france c'est malheureusement ou pour
certains mais c'est ce pays où on peut
ou on peut blasphémer si on a envie
contre toutes les religions ont là qui
est de haute lutte contre les
religion catholique contre catholicisme
politique c'est également le quand il a
été nommé quand il a été élu par dont il
a nommé un certain yassine belattar qui
s'illustrent justement dans cette
séparation mais je pense que ce
communautarisme et je pense que c'est ce
communautarisme qui doit être combattue
et donc pas que pas que celui de
certains islamistes mais l'ensemble de
ceux qui veulent distinguer les français
en rappelant que nous sommes une
république une et indivisible
la porte parole du gouvernement avait
pris des précautions déjà dès ce matin
le séparatisme ne doit pas être
mélangées avec l'ess fait le problème de
la laïcité nous partager ce constat
également oui tout à fait déjà déjà
quand on parle de séparatisme je pense
qu'il ne faut pas en déduire qu'il faut
stigmatiser au pointé du doigt
l'ensemble des citoyens français de
confession musulmane comme j'ai dit tout
à l'heure ce n'est pas lié à une
religion en particulier même s'il ne
faut pas être dans le déni
il ya certains qui ont une lecture
étriqué de la religion musulmane qui
essaie d'instrumentaliser qui essayait
de la dévoyée par quelques comportements
mais heureusement c'est une infime
minorité et il faut vraiment éviter de
généraliser
donc les musulmans de france sont
d'abord des citoyens à part entière et
non des citoyens entièrement à part ils
seront d'abord des citoyens avant d'être
des musulmans ils sont respectueux des
valeurs et des lois de la république et
il s'inscrit totalement dans la
république laïque une et indivisible
qu'on vous disiez et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire confiance
aux musulmans de france bien sûr il ya
des phénomènes très ciblée qu'il faut
combattre par la prévention c'est le
rôle des institutions religieuses
c'est aussi le rôle de l'état justement
par un certain nombre de lois du
disposition pour combattre ce
séparatisme
mais il faut surtout pas généraliser je
pense que le président de la république
a su trouver cet équilibre se heurte en
même temps ou à la fois ils dénoncent et
nomme les choses mais également il est
dans une démarche de rassemblement de la
communauté nationale et
et en essayant d'éviter de pointer du
doigt une religion en particulier aux
des citoyens d'une certaine profession
en particulier
oui parce que voilà peut-être qu'on
serait pas d'accord j'imagine c'est
pense en ce moment il est une 6 ème s'il
a une religion en tout cas pas
l'ensemble les religions mais les
éléments de l'islam politique qui pousse
au conflit c'est bien dans la région
dans l'islam comme ça a été le cas avec
les catholiques et jeux comme ça a été
le cas avec atelier lecture des voiliers
ou d'une instrumentalisation si vous
voulez mais là c'est pas le problème la
république de déterminer qui
théologiquement raison n'a pas raison
c'est juste que chacun quelle que soit
sa religion accepte les règles la
république et si les accepte pas on fait
comme mon affaire entre 1880 et 1905 jeu
même avant des délices et 189 ont fermé
condamnations et les gens mettent un
genou à terre et prête serment devant la
constitution ils acceptent les valeurs
de la république où ils s'en vont
et d'ailleurs beaucoup de catholiques
d'alors dans les congrégations étaient
fermées lors bien ôter prive que l'on ne
rappelait à cette extrêmement dur ce
combat sont partis en belgique en
allemagne pour parce que là bas ils
n'avaient plus le droit de vivre de
manière communautariste avec les grandes
croix et petit jésus partout c'est un
peu la même chose avec les sommes et là
où je viens vous n'êtes pas d'accord et
vous c'est que quand vous avez présidé
le cfcm vous avez poussé au port du
voile
or le port du voile pour moi qui suis un
laïc a c'est assez radical
c'est une forme de séparation de mama
maman ma maman était était dans les
années 60 est levée par les bonnes
soeurs de la doctrine chrétienne
à 14 ans elle était intimement convaincu
que si elle s'asseyait derrière monsieur
dans un bus allaient tomber enceinte je
pense que c'est une très très mauvaise
idée que des gens en particulier que les
femmes ou parce que nous sommes une
république où il l égalité entre les
femmes mettent des idées saugrenues dans
la tête des femmes ou les sépare du
reste de la communauté puisque le voile
est une séparation du reste de la
communauté
avec l'idée qui est quand même assez
étonnante construction regarde le cag
rivaux en ce moment que les femmes sera
responsable de l'excitation qu'elle
provoquerait auprès des hommes donc
voilà ça je pense qu'il faudrait
combattre
on a pris ce sens vous permettez vous
avez commencé par rappeler qu'on est
dans une république laïque la laïcité à
ce que je sache c'est la garantie de la
liberté de conscience la liberté de
croire et de ne point crois et c'est la
garantie c'est l'état qui lui doivent
garantir que pour tous ceux qui voyaient
croyances de ne pas l'avoir assez égal
voire de pouvoir vivre pleinement sa
religion dans le respect des lois et des
valeurs de la république a bien
évidemment et ses essais et c'est le cas
de l'immense de la quasi-totalité des
musulmans de france qui sont respectueux
des valeurs et des lois république ce
que vous avez dit également c'est que la
république et le présenta république l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises c'est la
république éric ce n'est pas la société
qui est laïque et d'ailleurs il a le
président de la république a dit que le
port du voile ou de signes religieux
dans l'espace public c'est pas son
affaire face c'est le mot qu'il avait
qu'il avait utilisé par contre la
laïcité effectivement ça c'est la
neutralité des services de l'état c'est
l'autre alité des agents de l'état pas
des usagers des services publics mais
des agents des services tels alors je
pense que l'exemple du voile c'est il
relève du choix de chacun de femmes ou
hommes de se conduire et de se conformer
à tel ou tel précis prescription
religieuse mais il ne faut pas faire
d'amalgamé entre les choix
vestimentaires que peuvent prendre untel
ou untel et notamment les femmes est
elle à pied soins d'égalité en france je
vous rejoins entièrement qu' il faut
assurer une égalité parfaite entre les
hommes et les femmes avec les mêmes
droits et les mêmes devoirs et je sais
que la religion musulmane les
interpeller régulièrement là dessus et
quand j'étais président du cfcm j'avais
une vraie pour que des femmes soient au
sein du cfcm
nous avons créé une instance de dialogue
avec des fins pour pouvoir être à leur
écoute est ras jédir et répondre à leurs
attentes et prendre en compte leurs
oeufs leurs propositions donc je pense
que nous allons nous améliorer l'action
intéressant ce qu'on a et anouar kbibech
parce que le gouvernement justement veut
s'appuyer sur le cfcm à leur conseil
français du culte musulman
qu'est ce que ça a donné vos efforts
pour rétablir une forme d'égalité on a
vu quand même que ce fcm s'était
illustré
ça a été critiqué lors de la ferme il a
il faisait référence
en gros la bien cherché c'était ce café
voix a été la déclaration du conseil
français du culte musulman ça vous
attriste genre de sorties bon moi je
pense que le cfcm a pris conscience
justement que la religion musulmane
était régulièrement interpellé au sein
de la source des français et par les
autorités par les différents partis
politiques et l'ensemble nos concitoyens
sur l'égalité hommes-femmes et là dessus
il ya des propositions concrètes qui ont
été formulées et aujourd'hui à des
femmes qui sont rentrés pour la première
fois au conseil d'administration du cfcm
et j'espère bientôt au bureau du safe 50
dont il ya des avancées maintenant à la
ferme il a effectivement elle a donné
lieu à plusieurs interprétations à
plusieurs prises de position je pense
que la question du blasphème a été
réaffirmée la possibilité de blasphème a
été réaffirmée par plusieurs
responsables politiques ou religieux et
globalement je pense qu'on est dans un
thé dans un pays de la liberté
d'expression il faut respecter la
période des uns et des autres mais c'est
également la liberté d'un croyant quand
il voit sa propre religion insulté de
dire qu'il est blessé
alors bien sûr ça ne m'excuse en aucun
cas où nous semble justifier aucun cas
des appels au meurtre ou des intérêts
les différentes insultes qui ont déferlé
sur les réseaux sociaux mais par contre
il faut effectivement puis va pouvoir
construire ce vivre ensemble entre les
différents points de vue dont le respect
de la liberté d'expression des uns et
des autres alors on va aller dans le
cadre de sujet on va les écouter
emmanuel macron qui a fait quelques
annonces tout de même emmanuel macron
qui a souhaité a annoncé qu'il
souhaitait arrêter le système des imams
en détacher bon former des imams
directement sur le sol français
aujourd'hui on a je le disais 300 imams
détachées qui sont envoyées en france
chaque année
et donc ce qu'ils sont et 20 en 2020
seront la dernière génération avec ce
volume et nous allons progressivement
sortir c'est à dire ne plus en faire
venir de nouveaux et laisser la période
de présence des dernier imam détachées
se poursuivre jusqu'à son terme avec là
aussi un dialogue une amélioration
des conditions en parallèle de sa ce que
nous devons faire est ce que nous allons
faire c'est g revenir dans un instant
former des imams en france pour qu'ils
puissent maîtriser la langue et les lois
de la république
donc nous allons ainsi progressivement
mettre fin au système des imams
détachées et là aussi de manière
progressive
opsahl mots durs qui sont accueillis
spécifiquement chaque année à l'occasion
du ramadan
il y en a environ 300 cette sortie de ce
qu'on appelle l'islam consulaire est
elle aussi extrêmement importante pour
pouvoir réduire ses influences
étrangères
et là aussi permettre de s'assurer que
chacune et chacun respecte pleinement
les lois de la république dans un cadre
qui est connu de tous
georges que ce banovic et la bonne voie
que prend emmanuel macron arrêté système
d ea même détachée notamment a été
l'influencé étrangère
oui ça peut rester c'est pour rester
lettre morte
et puis c'est pas la seule ne s'est pas
la seule mesure c'est pas la seule
mesure à prendre
tu es toujours un peu circonspect avec
monsieur macron sur ces questions là je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure
monsieur maquereau et le président de la
république française donc de tous les
français même s'il a été élu que par une
petite partie d'entre eux du premier
tour il est censé défendre la laïcité
or il a été un des premiers à l'avoir
attaqué lorsqu'il est allé rompre l'
iftar ne la souhaitait rencontrer les
protestants de france lorsqu'il va au
ccf pardon au crif au crif pas au crif
ou alors pire encore lorsqu'il est allé
rencontrer les évêques de france alors
qu'il rend compte qu'il veut mais qu'ils
disent aux évêques de france
le lien entre la république à église a
été rompu nous allons leur nous et c'est
justement il a été rompue c'était
l'objectif omdh en 1905 donc rien à
renouer du tout de la même manière
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
philippe a déclaré qu'il faudrait une
laïcité apaisée
parce que vous est ce qu'on serait pour
une liberté apaisé non la laïcité est
laïcité point elle est ni apaisé ni
modéré n'est rien du tout et on est dans
un pays laïque alors maintenant sur 7
sur cette question des imams il me
semble je ne suis pas théologiens du
tout ni l'islam ni aucune autre religion
mais il me semble que c'est
il n'y a pas vraiment de clergé on n'est
pas tout à fait exactement dans l'église
catholique ou orthodoxe
c'est un choix des croyants parmi ceux
qui sont les plus sages de la communauté
alors ça ressemble plus au
protestantisme cac au catholicisme de ce
point de vue là donc qui va les former
comment par contre monsieur macron peut
immédiatement aurait pu prononcer deux
mesures s'est gelé les avoirs de
quelques milliards de certains princes
saoudiens jusqu'à ce qu'il dégage par
eux mêmes tout ce qu'ils ont mis ici et
tous leurs prédicateurs qui sont un
vecteur de du salafisme du thatchérisme
et les renvoyer dans leurs dents où ils
veulent dans le pays qu'ils veulent de
la même manière
exiger de l'ambassade des états unis qui
les arrêtent leur financement dans nos
cités dans nos banlieues du
communautarisme puisqu'ils ont une
vision c'est leur droit ils font ce
qu'ils veulent avec leur pays
visiblement ça ne marche pas très bien
en termes de lutte contre le racisme et
de et de flingage de de gens de couleur
par leur police
mais il serait bon que les acquis un
arrêt net du financement de ces pays là
qui font du une action de propagande
politique qui est contraire à ce qu'est
la république française l'a déjà par
rapport au président de la république
idées voire est la laïcité en allant à
la rencontre d'un certain nombre de
communautés spirituelles ou religieuse
un j'ai eu l'honneur en tant que
président du cfcm en juin 2010 est de
recevoir le président de la république
pour la première fois un iftar du cfcm
et je peux vous dire que les citoyens
français de confession musulmane qui
sont des français est également ont été
très touché par ce geste du président de
la république est d'ailleurs une partie
du discours qu'a tenu aujourd'hui le
président de la république à mulhouse
il a été tenu devant les représentants
du culte musulman donc c'est la
république effectivement dans le cadre
laïc ne reconnaît aucun culte mais nommé
connais aucun culte
les musulmans de france sont là les
protestants de france en larmes si les
gâteaux
face à ces différentes connaître et
participera fin du jeu je continue le
concordat napoléon bonaparte fermée vue
sillage des loisirs et les évêques dont
mais parfois vous verrez jamais dans une
église et bien sûr il est venu il a fait
passer un certain nombre de metz lundi
très très fort ça tous les musulmans de
france et ça a été pratiquement une
feuille de route pour les 2 3 ans qui
viennent et moi c'est une question un
peu naïve mais pourquoi at on besoin de
reconnaissance
peu importe qu'on soit juifs catholiques
bouddhistes c'est un élément qui sera
sur ses droits reconnus par le président
c'est un élément de considérations ici
également un dialogue républicain qui se
passe dans différentes instances
nettement par rapport au 10 mai les
répliques injustement par rapport aux
imams des dialogues religieux non pas du
tout parce que le discours qu'a tenu le
président de la république à l'iftar du
cfcm n'est pas n'était pas du tout un
discours religieux s'étaient qu'est ce
qu'un pan de la république est ce
qu'attend la société française des
musulmans de france
menouar kbibech pour revenir sur ces
imams étrangers s vous pour vous c'est
prendre le problème dans dans le
par le bon bout jeu au sol et nadia est
maintenant tout à l'heure me dire mais
les imams les plus radicalisées entre
guillemets ce sont des imams français
nés en france et pas forcément ceux qui
viennent de l'étranger est ce que ça
vous paraît être pertinents justement il
se trouve que en tant que président du
rassemblement des musulmans de france
c'est moi qui était à l'origine de la
venue de 38 membres d'être à son image
ça m'aide à l'interdît qu'est ce que tu
as l'autre réac alors justement à
l'époque
en 2008 nous avons fait un état des
lieux et nous avions un besoin criant
d'imams un imam s'assoiront pas du jour
au lendemain il faut au moins cinq ans
pour former un imam digne de ce nom avec
des gens qui qui doit avoir la vocation
de devenir imam donc le fait de recourir
à des imams détachées et une solution à
court et moyen terme ce n'est pas du
tout la solution 'un cible la solution à
long terme et donc c'était une solution
dans laquelle nous avons pu avancer
combler un certain vide qui existait
déjà
comme la nature a horreur du vide ça a
évité à des imams autoproclamés devenir
de d'avancer et de conduire la prière et
donc commencé à orienter les fidèles
mais bien sûr on est tous d'accord qu'il
faut des imams franco français formé en
france et c'est l'ensemble des
fédérations musulmanes au service elle
travaille dans ce sens et femmes et par
qui certes ont d'après il ya deux deux
aspects de la formation est là il ya la
formation civils et civiques et
aujourd'hui elle est administrée dans
deux ans dans d une vingtaine
d'universités françaises est soldée par
un diplôme universitaire et puis à la
formation théologique
je suis là par avez-vous là dessus ce
n'est pas le rôle de l'état de forme sur
le plan théologique
donc c'est le rôle des fédérations
musulmanes et le cros et français du
culte musulman devrait contribuer à
trouver des solutions pour mettre en
oeuvre des formations sur le plan
théologique des imams de france en
france et je pense que le cfcm s'y
emploie mais est-ce que vous soyez
d'accord pour que les imams venant
d'étrangers d'ailleurs ou français
prêtent serment à la constitution et aux
valeurs de répliques il se trouve que
quand j'étais président pour ce qui est
du cern mais on a établi une charte de
l'imam dans laquelle tout inna kyssil
cette charte s'engagent à faire une
prière ou à la république pendant le à
la prière du vendredi
il menace est pas un c'est pas la
question est posée bien sûr
il a vu les français de confession
musulmane considère que les valeurs et
les lois de la république ne sont pas
gérées en dessous des valeurs bien
évidemment mais la plupart et la plupart
des musulmans que je connais ce sont
comme beaucoup de catholiques tout à
fait en pratique tout à fait légère de
leur religion familiale une personne ne
les embête et ils n'embêtent personne
elle va tout va très bien
non je vous posais une question très
très clair est ce que vous êtes d'accord
que les imams faux pas des français
musulmans
les imams donc ceux qui vont professé
prête serment devant la constitution et
devant les valeurs de la république
c'est ça pour moi après la formation
c'est pour ça que je parle de la surface
comme l'achat de les banques c'est une
scène de la race en mai spriet a pris s
naulleau dans la charte de l'immeuble
c'est une déclaration solennelle que
fait l'image en s'engageant sur le
discours qu'il va porter auprès des
fidèles qui soit 1 10 ports et
respectueux des valeurs et des lois de
la république
donc je vous invite à consulter cette
charge des limandes donc c'est une
déclaration solennelle
maintenant ce que vous proposez je n'ai
aucun souci pour que les imams le fasse
à condition que les autres ministres de
culte des autres élèves le demande je
vous demande parce que c'est ce que nous
avons fait avec les prêtres catholiques
l'agent franc serait bien nous a fait
plus apporté beaucoup disent à la maison
fatalement mesures discriminatoires et
isuzu non sens total
vous avez entièrement raison il faudrait
pas que soit entendu comme des mesures
discriminatoires région particulière
c'est pour ça que l'histoire est
importante sur cet incident est beaucoup
de jeunes beaucoup de jeunes pensent que
la laïcité ou ces mesures là sont une
action et y ait des artistes sont une
action spécifique contre les musulmans
il est ce nécessaire de rappeler mais
qu' on a été d'abord très très dur avec
les catholiques ils ont prêté serment
c'est la constitution civile du clergé
et certains il ya eu des guerres certain
intérêt aux jsa ses partenaires passé
pour tout le monde musulman sur l'autre
mesure qui auront
parle-moi mais qui quand même est
importante à mon sens l'art et d
enseignement en langue étrangère elle qu
en gros on enseignait voilà ça touche
évidemment l'algérien l'italien aussi
mais enfin on sait ce qui est visé
effectivement dans ce discours ces
essais voilà le tunisien algérien ça me
choque ça non je pense que la
proposition du président de la
république va dans le bon sens mais elle
va dans le sens d'institutionnaliser une
un enseignement des langues d'origine ou
de culture d'origine dans le cadre
républicain et le fait d'enseigner par
exemple jack lang propose que la langue
arabe soit une langue parmi les langues
vivantes qu'on apprend dans l'école de
la république c'est également un moyen
pour barrer la route un certain nombre
d'écoles qui musulmane entre guillemets
coraniques ou autres qui n'ont pas
pignon sur rue et dans lesquels on sait
pas très bien ce qui se passe donc le
fait de d'institutionnaliser
enseignements de ces langues à travers
des agents de l'état rémunérés par
l'état français et va dans le bon sens
la question centrale est fondamental lé
monde combien monsieur macro est
déconnecté de la société française
messieurs macro est l'incarnation le
parangon du néo libéralisme politique
le problème des locaux de ses
professeurs qui viennent de l'étranger
mais c'est quoi ce hangar a fait en
portugais en italien et vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'il ya plus de
financement par la république de deux
futurs professeurs dans ces langues là
donc il faut bien se rabattre sur ce que
proposent les ambassades quels que
soient les pays
évidemment ceux qui auraient un intérêt
à pousser une l'islamisme politique
bon bah vous infiltrer deux ou trois
professeurs mais c'est globalement quel
problème
on peut par parra pour le coup il s'agit
pas de religion on peut parfaitement
avoir des agrégés de langue arabe en
français qui passent par lui rester
française et enseigne à l'école
sauf que en étant tenant d'une ligne
libérale économique
eh ben on a un président qui dans la
continuation des précédents saborde
savoir la république ne finance pas
l'école ne finance pas la police ne
finance pas tous les services publics
saborde l'hôpital et quand aujourd'hui
des jeunes lui ont dit à mulhouse il
faudrait plus de république
ils ont raison parce que quand tu es
moins de république qu'à terme on
travaille quand on est perdu au fond de
sa cité eh ben on finit dans une dans
une communauté quelle qu'elle soit donc
il faut plus de république sa demande
d'arrêter d'obéir aux critères de
convergence l'union européenne et donc
de financer la réplique française
merci anouar kbibech merci georges cosma
de vie tout avoir été avec nous c'est la
fin de ce journal on se retrouve dans
quelques petites minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité du jour
[Musique]
dans le sport l'institution du sport
pourquoi est-elle défaillante dans le
sens il ya quand même deux fois plus
d'agressions sexuelles peu dans dans le
monde hors sport faut les prédateurs
sexuels c'est plus et pratique le monde
du sport parce qu ils s'infiltrent vers
le toucher berlin team de la tête au fil
des années on voit bien que la place de
l'entraîneur est de plus en plus
prégnante est importante au sein du
sport aujourd'hui c'est une figure qui
est central dans l'écosystème c'est
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est souvent
sacralisé et puis il ya aussi la
domination adultes enfants il faut se
prendre par la main il faut travailler y
fait il faut accompagner les athlètes
il faut il faut les accompagner
juridiquement psychologiquement
médicalement socialement c'est pas
d'hystérie
c'est pas un buzz c'est la réalité on
est un malin ce qui est le fondement du
sport à savoir ses valeurs
[Musique]
un bon sapeur c'est quelqu'un d'être
agressif mais je vous dirais déjà paris
sont peut être sûr qu aujourd'hui
pouvait faire tous les kilomètres vous
devrez pas quelqu'un on ne tourne on en
plein mois de novembre à bien comme ça
j'aime tout sauf l anonymat l'anonymat
devait se monter ce poids tu viens de
chez toi tu vas au boulot tu reviens
personne tu as dit monsieur madame vous
êtes et les gaulois la vie est belle en
couleurs pourquoi diable ou là vous vous
arrêtez au noir bleu marine j'ai dû nous
c'est pas possible ça sert à rien
l'habille le sapeur fait jouer à l'ebit
son premier rôle qui ne sait ce qui ne
devait pas cessé d'être un vecteur de
communication
mais la sape basse et c'est sur le vivre
ensemble via la bi
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous êtes deuxième journée l'examen de
la réforme
à l'assemblée nationale après des
premiers échanges parfois houleux les
députés se sont attaqués aujourd'hui aux
milliers d'amendements d opposition
alors que dans le même temps s'ouvrait
la conférence de financement en présence
des partenaires sociaux
lutter contre toutes manifestations du
séparatisme islamistes emmanuel macron
visite à mulhouse nous a dévoilé son
plan de bataille
parmi les annonces le chef de l'état a
indiqué son souhait de mettre fin au
système des imams des tâches est envoyé
en france par d'autres pays et sa
volonté de favoriser l'organisation du
culte musulman
julien assange reçoit le soutien d'un
groupe de 110 est médecin qui dénonce la
torture psychologique infligé au
fondateur de wikileaks
une lettre publiée dans la revue
médicale the lancet t qui met en pause
le gouvernement britannique
un tribunal qui discutera de
l'extradition du fondateur de wikileaks
vers les états unis la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez deuxième jour de
débats donc sur la réforme des retraites
pour les députés au menu les amendements
déposés par l'opposition ils sont très
nombreux et plus de 40000 déposé en
majorité par les insoumis et des
communistes une journée de travail
chargée donc mais aussi houleuse retour
sur une journée de débats avec notre
reporter humain aussi
les députés ont commencé à examiner les
premiers des quelques quarante deux
mille amendements déposés pour ces deux
projets de loi ordinaire et organique de
cette réforme des retraites alors en
réalité on n'en est même pas au contenu
de la réforme puisque les derniers
amendements examinés au cours de cette
séance concerner seulement le titre du
projet de loi ordinaire
alors au delà du travail de fourmi
auquel se sont attelés les députés
plusieurs annonces ont été faites par le
président de la chambre premièrement
concernant les délais dont va disposer
l'assemblée nationale pour examiner le
texte
une semaine supplémentaire de débats et
une pause dans les travaux
parlementaires fixée au 6 mars pour les
élections municipales
notre disposition a été prise par
richard ferrand considérant que la
france insoumise et le parti communiste
faisait preuve d' obstruction
parlementaire du fait du trop grand
nombre d'amendements similaires déposées
il a été décidé qu'il n'y aurait plus
qu'un seul orateur par amendement pour
chacun de ces deux groupes
une disposition qui bien sûr a fait
vivement réagir l'opposition qui lui a
fortement déplu mais cette opposition
comptent bien poursuivre sa stratégie
écouter m'ont dit tous d'accord que
cette réforme est mal ficelé elle n'est
pas clair elle est belle est
incompréhensible et en fait elle va
détruire les retraites des français
voilà la réalité
vous comprenez plus ça va vite - les
français seront au courant de ce qui se
trame de ce qu'il ya derrière et nous
notre rôle c'est d'être les porte voix
des français donc plus c'est long plus
le gouvernement va perdre des plumes et
plus les français vont dire aux députés
en marge mais comment vous pouvez voter
ça l'objectif c'est on sait qu'ici ça
peut passer
ils ont la majorité pour ça d'une
manière ou d'une autre maintenant il
faut que ça passe dans la douleur et pas
que ça passe comme dans du beurre c'est
l'objectif
donc il faut que ils le traînent leurs
projets il avait qu'à pas le passé en
procédure accélérée il avait qu'à nous
donner du temps on était supposé dire ça
en trois jours bon voilà donc qu'on ne
dise pas que c'est nécessaire de passer
ça avant les municipales en avait déjà
blackrock qui a félicité le gouvernement
en disant ce que vous faites c'est très
bien mais là on a lampert la plus grande
association de d'assurer d'accord qui en
fait est liée à que ça aussi et qui dit
maintenant une chose est sûre se
constituer à titre individuel un
complément de retraite en vue de sept
jours va devenir inévitable pour
compenser la baisse annoncée des
pensions de retraite voilà la vérité
c'est donc une guerre d'usure qui se
déroule actuellement ici au palais
bourbon entre d'un côté le gouvernement
et la majorité et de l'autre
l'opposition une guerre d'usure qui
pourrait bien tourner court aujourd'hui
le nouveau ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand a laissé entendre que le recours
aux 49 3 n'était pas exclue même s'il
n'était pas encore à l'ordre du jour
dans le même temps la conférence de
financement un député aujourd'hui
objectif ramener l'équilibré le système
de retraite d'ici à 2027
les organisations syndicales et
patronales ont jusqu'à fin avril pour
trouver une solution alternative à
l'instauration d'un âge pivot de 64 ans
ce matin devant le ministère des
solidarités la santé cyril chabanier
président de la cftc s'est montré plutôt
optimiste même s'il précise que les
choses vont être très difficiles
ça sera difficile puisqu'on n'est pas
tous d'accord sur le principe même même
delà de la réforme comme venait de le
répéter mais je pense qu'on a un
véritable enjeu on doit on doit réussir
à se mettre d'accord à trouver un
compromis je pense que c'est peut-être
un peu la dernière chance pour montrer
que le dialogue social dans ce pays peut
aboutir un consensus à un compromis
si on n'y arrive pas je pense qu'on a le
risque de donner du grain à moudre à
ceux qui pensent que cela violence peut
arriver à obtenir des résultats
donc je pense qu'on a vraiment un très
très gros enjeu en tout cas pour la ctc
on nous fera tout pour qu'on puisse
aboutir à cette conférence mais à
condition encore une fois que que
l'effort soit équilibré pour pierre
roger secrétaire national cf cgc la
course l équilibre financier ne justifie
pas une réforme dans l'urgence et des
retraites ne sont pas en danger a pas de
problème de retraite à 2027 il ya
simplement un problème de recettes ou
l'état a décidé de ne plus apporter sa
contribution comme aujourd'hui donc de
ce fait sacrer un déficit est ce que
pour autant ces graves
alors je rappelle quand même que on
parle de 12 milliards à l'horizon 2027
par an en face le retraite c'est 300 à
325 milliards chaque année et on à 140
milliards de réserve par ailleurs
enfin en 2024 fin 2024 la cades est la
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale aura totalement remboursé la
dette
et ça libère par an environ 17 milliards
pris comme ça est ce qu'on est obligé
nécessairement le pronom mesure
uniquement sur l'âge nous on pense qu'on
peut trouver une autre solution ce qui
est frappant dans cette conférence c'est
que tout le monde ya participé
oui sauf le temple wire les suites de la
sphère griveaux à présent dans
l'actualité piotr pas plein ce qui est
sa compagne alexandra de taddeo ont tous
deux été mis en examen et placé sous
contrôle judiciaire
l'activiste russe risque par ailleurs
toujours la détention provisoire pour
des faits de violences remontant au 31
décembre 2019
l'avocat juan branco qui le représentait
renonce de son côté à le défendre
je lui ai suggéré quand la situation
actuelle il valait mieux qu'il prenne un
nouveau conseil à qui j'ai demandé s'il
acceptait de prendre le dossier
maître yassine bouzrou 1,3 yassine
bouzrou va épauler piotr pawlenty qui
mettre en visibilité
les problèmes procéduraux gravissimes
qui ont sali on a été confronté dans
cette procédure depuis le début et pour
stéphane rozès président de cap conseils
analyses perspectives enseignant à
sciences po et hec l'exécutif pointe la
question des réseaux sociaux comme
système de défense dans cette affaire il
ya des lois en la matière et évidemment
on comprend pourquoi l'exécutif a voulu
n'ont pas autant focalisé sur la faute
faites par benjamin griveaux qui a de
lui-même rendu possiblement que blick
quelque chose lié à sa vie privée
d'autant
fus a fortiori vu les circonstances de
la relation avec la personne et donc on
comprend bien pourquoi en réaction
défense l'exécutif a voulu pointer au
fond ce qui ont instrumentalisé et
question des réseaux sociaux donc
logiquement et puis il ya aussi il ya
une législation sur l'utilisation des
deniers ou par la justice entre part je
suis pas d'ailleurs du tout apprécié de
ces questions là donc la justice va
faire son travail inculpé ça veut pas
dire pas mais c'est assez logique au
fond on s'y attendait un tout petit peu
que effectivement la justice soit saisie
inverse une fin de l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est en tout cas
ce qu'a évoqué ce dernier scandale
politique conséquence plusieurs
personnalités politiques demandent la
fin de cet anonymat parmi elles le
secrétaire d'état au numérique
aujourd'hui on considère communément que
ce qui est en ligne
c'est moins grave que ce qui est commis
dans la vraie vie il faut inverser la
logique il y as en ligne une quasi
impunité
nous devons mettre à jour nos processus
judiciaire ils doivent se voir appliquer
une supervision et à contrôler
systémique
l'anonymat est une honte le premier
décourager de signer d'assumer ce que
l'on dit et pour thierry vallat avocat
au barreau de paris spécialiste des
questions numériques l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux n'existe tout simplement
pas c'est ridicule et ça démontre bien
là l'écart qu'il y as entre ces gens qui
ne connaissent absolument pas le monde
numérique et la réalité de ce que on vit
aujourd'hui avec internet et les réseaux
sociaux l'anonymat ça n'existe pas sur
internet
combien de fois faudra-t-il le répéter
le pseudonymat existe revanche et permet
à tout un chacun de pouvoir choisir de
s'exprimer sous ce pseudonyme se donne
ima anonymat quelle distinction quelle
sanction c'est que pseudonyme ah bon
vous vous appelez choupinou 123 et vous
signez sous 7
vous pouvez très bien être retrouvés sur
les réseaux sociaux de manière
extrêmement facile il suffit de demander
votre identifiant aux plateformes qui
qui vous héberge c'est tout à fait tout
à fait normales et la 2 nîmes a de toute
façon c'est la même chose vous avez
chaque empreinte numérique que vous m
mettez sur la toile et indélébile elle
est fixée avec une adresse qu on appelle
adresse ip il suffit que la police
judiciaire comptant l'un des gros qu'ils
cherchent
et c'est effectivement qui se trouve
derrière cette adresse ip et on retrouve
facilement votre ordinateur grand macron
100k s'engage contre ce qu'ils appellent
le séparatisme islamistes le chef de
l'état est à mulhouse il a présenté des
mesures de son plan de lutte contre le
séparatisme extrémistes au sein de la
république
parmi les annonces à retenir c'est c'est
progressif
d'accueillir des imams détachées envoyés
par d'autres pays favorisé également
l'organisation du culte musulman ou
encore accompagner davantage les
associations et collectivités
territoriales notre ennemi et à ce titre
le séparatisme c'est à dire ce phénomène
que nous observons depuis des décennies
qui est une volonté de quitter la
république de ne plus en respecter les
règles d'un mouvement de repli qui en
raison une croyance et d'appartenance
vise à sortir du champ républicain est
ce que nous avons à faire mais pas comme
j'ai parfois entendu chez certains un
plan contre l'islam
ce serait une faute profonde cette
stratégie de lutte contre le séparatisme
islamistes
elle doit se construire un musée autour
de quatre lignes de force
la première c'est de reprendre le
contrôle et de lutter contre les
influences étrangères en particulier à
l'école et dans les lieux de culte c'est
ce sur quoi je veux surtout aujourd'hui
m'exprimer la deuxième c'est de
favoriser une meilleure organisation de
culte musulman en france justement dans
le respect de la laïcité et pour
s'assurer du respect de toutes les lois
de la reppe troisième ligne de force
c'est de lutter avec détermination
contre toutes les manifestations du
séparatisme islamistes et du repli
communautariste qu'il génère mais qui
contreviennent aux lois et règlements
c'est à dire rentrer dans le détail ce
que je viens d'évoquer
et point par point là où la loi est
ambigu là où des pratiques se sont
développées pouvoir y répondre avec
beaucoup de calme et la quatrième ligne
de force c'est de pouvoir partout
ramener la république
là où elle a un peu démissionner où elle
n'a pas toujours été au rendez-vous ou
des difficultés sont apparues que nous
n'avons pas su résoudre comme il se
devait et pour jean luc mélenchon
président du groupe allait fille l
assemblée nationale toutes les questions
soulevées par le président macro
ressorte déjà de la loi française au
coeur
la licité quand il ya un problème en
premier lieu il faut regarder ce que la
loi ne permet pas de traiter dans ses
problèmes en toutes les questions ont
été soulevées par le président de la
république reçoit d'ores et déjà de la
loi ce qui est en cause en matière de
religion
à la différence de nombre d'autres
polémiques d'avoir zappé le livre c'est
que la religion plus tard à la fois et
la foi est toujours extrêmement active
et qui ne reste pas dans le dialogue et
la radio cavelier quand je sais la paix
civile près selon hédiard et maintenant
président de la brigade des mers il est
temps pour le gouvernement
des manuels macron de prendre les
mesures pour lutter contre le
communautarisme
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on attend
que justement justement notre président
se manifestent justement alors moi j'ai
ramené de courrier alors on a écrit un
courrier on peut le 15 juin 2018 on
alerte monsieur notre manuel macron un
autre courrier le de ces juillet 2010
est effectivement où il fait part de la
situation dans les quartiers tout ça où
on a une réponse en me disant bravo pour
le travail que vous faites mais on n'a
aucun retour
alors aujourd'hui mais ce macron je
pense qu'ils vous voyez s'il est dans
son rôle quand il est dans la
communication qui s'est fait ici faire
et ses communiqués alors j'ai entendu
effectivement un moment donné par les de
réconquérir les quartiers alors
réconquérir ça veut dire je trouve le
mot un peu mignon réconquérir c'est
reprendre les quartiers de toute façon
ça veut dire qu'on les a perdus les
quartiers il parle d'échec clairement
d'un des chefs de communautarisme je
pense que lui il a commencé justement
son mandat avec ça faut pas oublier
qu'il a mis à la tête de liste pour les
îles de quartier nous a mis un humoriste
quelqu'un qui n'avait rien à voir avec
les quartiers il n'avait aucune
expérience de terrain
c'est son copain jeter mais là tu gères
les cartes et la preuve la personne a
démissionné et moi j'avais rencontré
monsieur président avant qu'ils soient
présents sept ou huit mois je lui avais
fait effectivement
une analyse de terrain notre inquiétude
est tous à ce qui se passe dans le
quartier
j'avais l'impression d'avoir en face de
moi quelqu'un je parlais d'un autre pays
et pas de la france est aujourd'hui
justement va revenir sur les mesures que
j'ai regardé avec mon équipe on a étudié
tout ça j'espère que ce n'est pas que de
la com
une centaine de médecins alertent sur
les conditions de détention de julian
assange dans un document publié dans une
revue médicale britannique il regrette
que le lanceur d' alerte n'est pas accès
aux soins alors qu'approche une échéance
capitale pour lui le 24 février julien
assange comparaîtra à londres en vue de
son extradition aux etats-unis et
précision de rania berrada ce ne sont
pas moins de 117 médecins de 18 pays qui
tire la sonnette d'alarmé dans une
lettre publiée ce lundi par la revue
britannique de l'enset ces
professionnels de la santé estime que
julian assange et sujet je cite à une
torture psychologique
il regrette que son droit fondamental à
des soins appropriés soient dénier
depuis que les médecins ont commencé à
examiner monsieur assange à l'ambassade
de l'équateur en 2015
les avis médicaux d'experts et les
recommandations urgente des médecins ont
toujours été ignorés
d'après les signataires les charges qui
pèsent contre le lanceur d'alert ne
doivent pas justifier ce qu'ils estiment
être une maltraitance
cette politisation des principes
médicaux fondamentaux nous préoccupe
profondément car elle a des implications
au delà du cas de julian assange
la maltraitance par négligence médicale
motivés par la politique crée un
dangereux précédent
compromettant en fin de compte
l'impartialité de notre profession
l'engagement pour la santé pour tous et
l'obligation de ne pas nuire
cette politisation du cas assange est
aussi au coeur des préoccupations de ses
soutiens lors d'une conférence organisée
ce mardi à londres
le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks a
estimé que cette affaire est aussi l'une
des attaques les plus graves contre le
journalisme ces dernières années
j'ai eu le privilège d'examiner
certaines pièces qui seront présentées à
la cour par les avocats de la défense de
julian dans mon esprit il ne fait aucun
doute absolument aucun doute qu'il
existe des arguments écrasant contre
cette demande d'extradition
c'était une affaire qui était simplement
juger en vertu des lois
je ne m'inquièterai pas du tout mais
c'est un cas politique et ce qui est en
jeu ici ce n'est pas seulement la vie de
julian assange qui risquent 175 ans de
prison s'il est extradé
c'est l'avenir du journalisme voilà quel
point cette affaire est importante
il s'agit de l'attaqué la plus grave
contre le journalisme dans le monde ces
derniers temps depuis son arrestation en
avril 2019 à l'ambassade d'équateur
julian assange est détenu à la prison de
belmarsh dans le sud de londres
le lanceur d'alert doit comparaître le
24 février en vue de son extradition
vers les états unis et pour nos amis
iyaz journaliste auteur de wikileaks le
quatrième pouvoir l'histoire en marche
l'arrestation de julian assange
l'exposent à de graves violations des
droits humains on écoute je pense qu'il
est important pour la communauté
internationale de comprendre que les
droits que julien assange ont été
violées par de nombreux qu'ils sont
humains occidentaux notamment par le
réunis
je viens un sens je n'ai pas accès à des
soins médicaux adéquats
il a également été soumis à des tortures
psychologiques selon le rapport du
spécialiste de l'ogn nice mais de ça
donc c'est très important que les
d'auteur et toutes les personnes qui se
préoccupent des droits de l'homme adopte
une position ferme
un plus de deux semaines après être
devenu effectif le président continue de
susciter le débat en europe
retour sur les dernières informations
avec valentin carpentier royaume unis et
union européenne se lance dans une
négociation aux allures de duel pour
obtenir le meilleur accord sûr de sa
force
chaque parti veut avoir le dernier mot
et c'est londres qui a lancé la dernière
attaque via son négociateur david frost
il est essentiel pour nous de pouvoir
établir des lois qui nous conviennent de
revendiquer le droit que possède tout
autre pays non membres de l'union
européenne dans le monde
il ne s'agit pas d'une simple position
de négociation qui pourrait changer sous
la pression c'est l'objectif même de
l'ensemble du projet la demande
britannique une négociation pour un
accord de libre-échange d'égal à égal
sans aucune intervention de l'union
européenne
quand le royaume uni fixera ses propres
règles une posture adoptée au moment où
les membres de l'ue élaborent un plan
avec son négociateur michel barnier pour
fixer ses objectifs dans le cadre de
cette négociation
le royaume uni a donc dégainé en premier
et s'est montré très clair
pour faire court tout ce que nous
voulons c'est ce dont bénéficient des
autres pays indépendant si nous pouvons
pas conclure un accord de libre échange
de types canadiens nous sommes prêts à
commercer dans des conditions similaires
à celles de l'australie
nous comprenons les compromis que cela
implique
le seul problème pour londres c'est que
bruxelles est également sûr de sa force
l'uae représente un énorme marché ne
compte pas se laisser faire michel
barnier avait d'ailleurs annoncé la
couleur quelques jours avant le 31
janvier duke et atx on tombait comme
third country
le royaume uni a choisi de devenir un
pays tiers de quitter le marché unique
et l'union douanière de laisser derrière
lui le cadre des règles communes de
l'union européenne
la surveillance commune et la cour de
justice comme usure
jeunes comme hancock justice il a choisi
de créer deux espaces réglementaire cela
rend impossible un commerçant friction
this makes friction laisse très impo
chez ball les pourparlers débuteront le
1er mars prochain et devront être bouclé
au plus tard le 31 décembre
en effet il ya bien un point sur
lesquels les deux parties sont d'accord
il n'y aura pas de prolongation de la
période de transition et londres
pourraient rester une ville européenne
le maire de la capitale anglaise indique
anne était à bruxelles ce mardi pour
rencontrer l'eurodéputé guy faire
hoofstadt objectif discuter de la
possibilité d'autoriser des
ressortissants britanniques à voyager et
à travailler dans les pays de l'ue sans
visa
face aux journalistes ça l'icann a
notamment émis l'idée d'une citoyenneté
par association qui permettrait aux
londoniens de garder leur citoyenneté
européenne
de nombreux londoniens ont le coeur
brisé du fait de notre départ de l'union
européenne mais nous avons toujours le
sentiment de faire partie de la famille
européenne nous sommes européens
nous avons toujours le sentiment de
faire partie du projet européen je veux
pousser d'autres villes et être proche
de nos amis en europe car ce sont nos
amis et même si nous avons quitté
l'union européenne se veut aussi voir
s'il ya la possibilité d'une sorte de
citoyenneté par association à l'avenir
je suis très heureux de la réaction à
bruxelles
et cela donne de l'espoir aux londoniens
et à tout ce dont notre pays qui
souhaitent maintenir une relation
étroite avec l'union européenne
c'est une main tendue que le
gouvernement britannique pourrait offrir
pour essayer d'unir à nouveau notre pays
alstom annonce le rachat de la branche
ferroviaire de son rival canadien
bombardier l'occasion pour la société
française de devenir le numéro deux
mondial du secteur
le rachat devrait avoisiner 6 milliards
d'euros mais il n'interviendra pas avant
une validation de la commission
européenne et précision dylan a fait
radiant avec cyrielle benavides but bull
est une sacrée revanche seulement un nom
après l'échec de la fusion alstom
siemens
le fabricant ferroviaire s'offre son
concurrent canadien
lundi après plusieurs semaines de
rumeurs autour du projet le p dg
d'alstom a annoncé la signature d'un
protocole d'accord pour acheter
bombardier transport montant de la
transaction de 5,8 à 6,2 milliards
d'euros l'occasion pour le fabricant du
tgv de doubler de volume et mieux
affronter une concurrence de plus en
plus vives
cette acquisition renforcera notre
présence internationale ainsi que notre
capacité à répondre à la demande
toujours plus importante de solutions de
mobilité durable
bombardier transport apportera à alstom
une complémentarité géographique et
industriels sur des marchés en
croissance
ainsi que des plateformes technologiques
additionnel les parts de l'entreprise
serait divisé la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec détiendrait 18 % les
parts de bouygues passerait de 15 % à 10
% et alstom disposerait du solde du
capital mais une étape primordiale reste
à venir
la validation du projet par la
commission européenne margrethe vestage
heures commissaire européenne en charge
de la concurrence et bruno le maire
ministre français de l'économie et des
finances s'entretiendront ce mardi à ce
sujet à bruxelles
je me réjouis qu'alstom à travers
l'acquisition de bombardier transport
jouent un rôle de premier plan dans le
renforcement de l'industrie ferroviaire
européenne
ce renforcement est plus que jamais une
priorité compte tenu des besoins
croissants en mobilité durable la
transaction est prévue pour le premier
trimestre 2001 21
si elle est une bonne nouvelle pour le
français elle représente aussi un
nouveau souffle pour le groupe canadien
qui était depuis quelques années en
difficulté financière et pour
l'économiste philippe muray re le rachat
de bombardier est un joli coup même si
aujourd'hui la france selon lui n'a pas
de véritable politique industrielle par
rapport à l'opération alstom siemens
aussi mince avec des capitaux allemand
racheté alstom avec tous les risques de
délocalisation
zine et d'emploi là c'est un joli coup
peut-être qu'on a plus data stratège on
n'a plus de vision stratégique et une
vraie politique industrielle là dessus
parce que ce qu'on pourrait faire
c'est que toutes les locomotives diesel
il y en a encore beaucoup en france tout
le réseau électrifié sur les petites
lignes notamment tous ces locomotives
diesel pour être remplacée un grand plan
à 5 10 ans par des locomotives à
hydrogène alstom avec un intérêt très
important c'est que ça ferait croître
l'écosystème hydrogène en france où
pourraient ensuite mettre les bus à
hydrogène dans toutes les villes comme
paris qui étouffe sous les particules
fines ou lyon est ensuite utilisé tous
et écosystèmes pour aller beaucoup plus
loin pour aller travailler que nos
constructeurs automobiles pour mettre en
place des voitures à hydrogène des
scooters à hydrogène en france et là on
aurait on ferait politique industrielle
emploi transition écologique
je pense que tout le monde serait ravi
la crise en libye les forces des stars
ont attaqué ce mardi le port de tripoli
pendant ce temps là a eu lieu à genève
la reprise des négociations militaires
ont fait le point avec les îles à saraf
le port maritime de tripoli la cible
d'une attaque provenant des forces du
maréchal khalifa haftar une colonne de
fumée épaisse visible dans la direction
de la zone portuaire un entrepôt aurait
été touché alors que la situation sur le
terrain reste une situation où la trêve
est très fragile et de nouvelles
attaques ont lieu aujourd'hui dans le
port de tripoli où des incidents se
produisent un peu partout
la situation ne change pas nos bas
personne n'a jusqu'à présent renier le
principe d' acceptation de la trêve le
processus politique essaie de trouver un
moyen d'aller de l'avant ce mardi les
négociations de la commission militaire
mixte sur la libye ont donc repris à
genève dans un contexte tendu
la veille l'union européenne a sacrifié
la mission de surveillance lancée en
2015 au large de la libye
by une nouvelle est programmée
prochainement pour empêcher les
livraisons d'armes aux deux camps qui
s'affrontent dans le pays
le nom sofia follerie ça n'existe plus
donc nous avons quand même trouvé un
accord politique
un agrément politique sur le futur pense
que nous avons tous commenté c'est
formidable on est maintenant sur le
niveau de des nations unies et ça va
plus aller dans la bonne direction
tripoli est depuis près d'un an la cible
d'une offensive lancée par l'armée
nationale libyenne
seul un accord pour un cessez-le-feu
stable garantira la tenue du sommet
politique prévue le 26 février prochain
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité ce sera demain 7h du matin
heure française
[Musique]
où
c'est à présent la route maritime du
nord est une route idéale pour relier
l'est à l'ouest
sur l'île de s un ours à manger un
collaborateur de la station
[Musique]
en ce moment tous les pays se bat pour
l'artiste donc si on ne la considère pas
maintenant quelqu'un de prendre place
c'est le sentiment que que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes poussent le fait de vivre
avec les plantes comme ça vraiment comme
une machine un organisme pour faire
partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps quand vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage
[Musique]
il creuse le sol pour me trouver
les uns y at il quelqu'un ici sortait
c'est un travail dangereux oui même les
enfants travaillent pour en extraire
essais par match et ça s'est calmé
[Musique]
des fraudes et votre manque berra comme
ça
[Musique]
c'est pourtant leur seul moyen de survie